Omega lul, Omega lul, Omega, Mega, Mega lul.
Okay, es sind ja schon Leute im Strebe.
Stimmt, ich habe ja ganz vergessen, ich habe ja vor 5 Minuten auf dem Discord geschrieben, geht jetzt los.
Normalerweise habe ich immer 5 Minuten Zeit oder so, bis Twitch die Ankündigung verschickt,
in dem ich in Ruhe alles starten kann und wo eh kein Mensch da ist.
Pock.
Okay, die ersten Leute sind schon am Start.
Es ging diesmal schneller mit Twitch, sonst braucht Twitch teilweise 5 Minuten,
bis sie diese Meldung verschickt, dass der Stream online ist.
Ja, MonkaWindows.
Übrigens, die eigentliche Sache, die ich heute im Stream machen wollte, wäre glaube ich...
Hat der Stream gerade gelaggt?
Wie?
Hat der Stream eigentlich gelaggt?
Ich glaube einfach nur, dass meine Vorschau gelaggt hat.
Ich glaube, das war einfach nur die Vorschau, die gelaggt hat.
Ich brauche übrigens immer noch Sub-Badges.
Hört mir gerade ein.
Vielleicht sollte ich Sub-Badges machen.
Ein Monat kriegst du ein Java-Icon und es wird dann immer eine bessere Sprache aus meiner Sicht pro Monat.
Das heißt, wenn man dann 12 Monate bei ist, kriegt man dann was ordentliches.
Kann man Jarrah nicht starten mit dem neuen Prozessor?
Hä?
Was hat ein Prozessor damit zu tun?
Das sollte ihm vollkommen egal sein.
Assembler.
Ja, mir ist noch nichts Gutes eingefallen.
Mir ist noch nichts Gutes eingefallen für Sub-Badges.
Weil die Dinger sind ja auch klein.
Die Dinger sind klein und viereckig.
Es gab letztens einen Ryzen-Bug, der System-D zum Crashen gebracht hat.
Aber ernsthaft?
Wie haben sie das geschafft?
Keine Ahnung, ich habe Ryzen noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ernsthaft?
Finde ich interessant.
Ich hätte gar nicht gedacht, dass es da tatsächlich irgendwelche Abhängigkeiten zu CPUs gibt.
Oder irgendwie Probleme mit CPUs.
Interessant, wusste ich nicht.
Ja, zumindest.
Also, die ursprüngliche Idee für den Stream heute war eigentlich,
dass wir einen Paket-Tracker versuchen zu programmieren.
Der Pakete-Tracker.
Also sowas hier wie...
Mir fällt jetzt kein Anbieter ein.
Pasello oder so gibt es da, glaube ich.
War das Pasello?
Bilder?
Ja, dass wir sowas hier versuchen mal selbst zu programmieren,
wo man dann einfach sieht...
Also mal die Map außen vor, auf die Daten habe ich keinen Zugriff.
Aber dass man hier einfach nur sieht, okay, es ist ein DHL-Paket unterwegs.
Ich habe mir gedacht...
Das könnte man folgendermaßen machen, weil die können ja auch alle nicht zaubern.
Also, oh, warte mal.
Es gab einen...
Der Zodiac abonniert Stufe 1.
Nice.
Dankeschön.
Und ganz wichtig...
Ähm...
Genau, und...
Die ganzen Apps, die es hier gibt, die können ja auch nicht zaubern, sowas einzuplanten.
Und ich habe gedacht, wir können das mal selbst machen, weil...
Das würde aus drei Teilen bestehen.
Vielleicht kann man ein paar DHL-Apps...
Ja, das müssen wir mal gucken.
Also, das würde prinzipiell aus drei Teilen bestehen.
Einmal einem Scanner, der quasi beliebige Quellen durchsucht nach Tracking-Numbers.
Weil, ich meine, wenn man das einfach von Hand adden muss, ist es ja langweilig.
Ich will das automatisch haben.
Und ich habe eine E-Mail, die verwende ich fast jedem Online-Shop.
Kennst du noch Fluffy Linux?
Ihh.
Das sieht aus wie Rebecca Black Linux oder so, was es mal gab.
Ähm, zumindest...
Um das hier noch kurz fertig zu erzählen, was ich eigentlich vorhabe.
Es würde dann einmal auch so ein Scanner bestehen.
Ich glaube, ich mache die Ärzte mal ein bisschen leiser, oder?
Die sind ein bisschen zu laut.
Die sind schon ganz unten.
So, hä?
Da ist besser.
Ähm...
Naja, ähm, zumindest...
Wollte ich...
Wollte ich da einmal einen Scanner bauen, der quasi guckt, ähm, in E-Mail-Postfächern nach oder in Textdateien nach, ähm, was man für Ver...
Was?
Idoris, zwölf Zuschauer, dankeschön.
Ein nicer Host.
Bin ich immer noch...
Jetzt bin ich voll aus dem...
Voll aus dem Konzept.
Das wollte ich dir jetzt gerade erzählen.
Genau.
Und, ähm, ich meine, ich weiß nicht, wie ihr das gemacht habt, aber ich habe das so...
Ich habe für alle Shops, sofern es irgendwie ging, die gleiche E-Mail-Adresse eingetragen.
Und das heißt, ich habe ein Postfach, wo ich auch die ganzen Sendebestätigungen hinkriege, wenn mir irgendwelche...
Pakete...
Wenn mir irgendwelche Shops irgendwelche Pakete schicken.
Und da habe ich mir überlegt, okay, man könnte ja was basteln, was dieses E-Mail-Postfach scannt,
sich dort quasi die, äh, Tracking-Numbers rausholt von den E-Mails, sofern die drin ist.
Dann bei den jeweiligen Anbietern nachguckt, wo das Paket ist, und das Ganze dann per Notification irgendwo hinschickt,
oder mal zumindest irgendwo zur Verfügung stellt, dass man woanders drauf zugreifen kann.
Soll denn ein schöner Gruß von einem Kollegen aus...
Vom Felix?
Der Felix...
Hä?
Ist der bei dir gerade, der Felix, oder?
Was ist los?
Das verwirrt mich jetzt.
Der Felix...
Ach, jetzt weiß ich, jetzt weiß ich, wie du bist.
Das hat mir der Felix letztens gezeigt.
Stimmt, der Felix hat mir letztens seinen Stream gezeigt.
Das ist ja, ähm, äh, Koch, genau, Koch-Stream.
Koch-Stream, so.
Ja, mittlerweile gibt es auf Twitch alles Mögliche, Leute.
Also, wenn ihr mal, wenn ihr, wenn ihr sehen wollt, wie man was ordentlich kocht, dann guckt mal beim...
Idoris vorbei.
Der Felix ist AFK, okay.
Ähm, so, Moment.
Wo war ich jetzt stehen geblieben?
Genau, und sowas habe ich mir gedacht, können wir basteln.
Das Problem dabei ist gar nicht mal die technische Umsetzung.
Die Sache ist viel eher, also das ist an sich auch nicht so einfach, aber es ging...
Das Problem ist eher, ich bräuchte Tracking-Number zum Testen.
Und wenn ich Tracking-Numbers verwende, von denen ich weiß, dass die funktionieren,
dann sind das meine eigenen Tracking-Numbers, und die will ich nicht im Stream zeigen.
Weil ich nicht meine Tracking-Number von DHL...
äh, im Stream verwenden will.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, das können wir wahrscheinlich eher nicht On-Stream machen.
Es sei denn, ähm, es stellen mir irgendwelche Leute ihre Tracking-Number zur Verfügung von UPS, DHL, Hermes und DPD.
Kannst Fake-Bestellungen machen.
Ja gut, die muss ich ja immer noch bezahlen, ne?
Das ist ja nicht so sinnvoll.
Dann mach ich ne Fake-Bestellung an Arsch der Welt, muss sie bezahlen und sie kommt nie an.
Das ist auch nicht im Sinne des Erfinders, oder?
Naja.
Und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, wir machen doch mal eine Sache,
die ich schon länger mal ausprobieren wollte.
Weil, ich will nicht sagen ein Freund, aber ein Bekannter von mir ist Lehrer.
Und die haben sich jetzt überlegt, ob die nicht an ihrer Schule, precisely Min PI J constitution,
ähm, Linux installieren auf ein paar Notebooks.
Nö.
Kann doch nicht so schwer sein...
Ja klar.
Ja klar, kann doch nicht so schwer sein.
Kann doch nicht so schwer sein.
eine Tracking-Nummer zu Brutforcen.
Das würde ich mal nicht sagen.
Die UPS-Tracking-Nummer sind 13
Stellen, die Dinger sind übelst lang
und nur 120 Tage gültig.
Das ist, glaube ich, gar nicht
so einfach, da eine Tracking-Nummer zu Brutforcen.
13 Stellen,
120 Tage gültig, da kannst du lange Brutforcen.
Genau, und die haben vor,
in der Schule
Linux zu installieren auf ein paar Notebooks
oder auf ein paar
Desktop-PCs,
eher auf ein paar Desktop-PCs, und hat mich
gefragt, ob ich nicht eine gute Einsteiger-Linux-Distribution
kenne, die was taugt.
Da habe ich gesagt, ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung,
ich verwende Manjaro, das ist allerdings nicht
einsteigerfreundlich.
Und wir könnten es übrigens mal
starten, fällt mir gerade ein,
bevor wir ewig
rumlabern.
Weil wenn ich das starte,
dann geht auch mein
Chat-Tool mal wieder, was ja gerade
kaputt ist. So, und da habe ich
aus, genau, schwarzes
Schwarz,
Sonnenjahr, genau das habe ich auch gesagt.
Ich habe gesagt, hier, weißt du was, mir
fällt gerade nichts ein, aber nehm einfach Ubuntu,
Ubuntu geht immer. Und das ist
auch so die Sache, wo man dann,
ähm, also die
Tracking-Nummer kannst du haben. Ah, das
ist gut, das ist gut, ich schreibe schon, also wenn du
nichts dagegen hast, können wir die in einem der nächsten Streams tatsächlich
verwenden.
Ja, stimmt, Leute,
ja, ihr habt ja recht.
Ubuntu ist viel zu normal, die
Aussprache, ja, ja, es muss ja Ubuntu
sein, verstehe, ja.
Oder wie der Typ letztens im Video,
Ubuntu,
Ubuntu war auch nicht schlecht, oder?
Ubuntu.
Ähm,
genau, habe ich ihm auch gesagt,
weißt du was, nimm einfach Ubuntu, das geht immer, da kannst
du nicht allzu viel falsch machen. Und dann habe ich mir
überlegt, okay, was gibt's
eigentlich noch,
was gibt's eigentlich noch so einsteigerfreundliche
Distributionen? Und da habe ich mal geguckt,
ähm, und das wollte ich mir schon
vor einer Weile mal angucken, was
es da für Möglichkeiten gibt, und da ist mir aufgefallen,
dass
Manjaro mittlerweile nicht mehr auf Platz 1 ist,
bei den beliebtesten Distributionen.
Man kann sich jetzt über die Statistik hier streiten,
aber das ist schon mal ein ganz guter Indikator.
Ähm, genau,
Gentoo. Sollte man
für die Schule etwas nehmen, wo man auch
einen Support-Kontakt, ja, nee, brauchen sie nicht,
die wollen einfach nur ein bisschen mit rumbasteln.
Er selbst ist ja auch nicht der, der,
der übelste Linux-Pro.
Also das muss sowohl was sein, was der Lehrer
halbwegs checkt, als auch was die Schüler
halbwegs checken, und im Zweifelsfall checken es die, die, die
Schüler eher als der Lehrer.
Also fällt sowas wie Manjaro und Gentoo schon mal raus.
Äh, für Gentoo musst
du ja erst einmal quasi ein halbes
Buch gelesen haben, dass du das Ding überhaupt installieren kannst.
Und, äh, wenn du
Manjaro-Minimal-Installer nimmst, dann
brauchst, musst du auch ein Buch gelesen haben, bis du dir grafische Oberfläche
installiert hast. Das ist alles schon
mal nicht, äh,
so Sinn und Zweck der Sache.
Und ich hab mal geguckt, was es jetzt gibt. Wie gesagt, Manjaro
ist immer noch relativ beliebt. Aber mir ist
aufgefallen, hier steht so ein komisches Ding, hab ich noch nie gehört
vorher hier. MX-Linux.
Steht hier oben.
Und, was
auch als sehr Einsteiger-freundlich
gilt, ist das da.
Das soll wohl besonders hübsch sein.
Das hab ich mir mal vor fünf Jahren
oder so angeguckt. Ist schon ewig her.
Und da hat es mir überhaupt nicht gefallen, weil es
einen übelst umständlichen Desktop hatte.
Und, das hab ich mir gedacht,
können wir jetzt mal ausprobieren, ob das wirklich was taugt.
Ähm,
an sich bin ich immer noch der Ansicht, mit Ubuntu fährst
du nicht schlecht als Einsteiger-Distribution.
Auch wenn ich die Oberfläche von
Ubuntu nicht schön finde.
Das ist eigentlich das schlechteste an Ubuntu,
dass, ähm, dass
der Desktop so scheiße aussieht.
Standardmäßig.
Früher mit Unity
noch schlimmer. Übrigens noch ein
Ding, was Unity heißt. Unity ist ja
mehrfach belegt. Unter Ubuntu meint
man mit Unity nicht die Spiele-Engine, sondern man meint
die alte Desktop-Umgebung.
Lassen sich Linux-Desktop
eigentlich irgendwie administrieren?
Wie meinst du das?
Meinst du wie Active Directory
Remote-mäßig?
Also, Linux-Desktop lassen sich genauso gut
administrieren wie alle anderen.
Remote, natürlich!
Remote-Administration oder Linux ist mit
SSH das Einfachste, was du machen kannst.
SSH, User,
Add, Name von der Kiste,
einloggen, fertig.
Das ist easy.
Das geht natürlich mit Linux-Desktops auch.
Und, ähm,
du kannst natürlich auch, wenn du grafische Oberfläche
haben willst, kannst du auch noch
VNC nehmen.
Ich glaube sogar Teamviewer gibt es mittlerweile
für Linux, wenn man dann
einverstanden damit ist, dass man über die Teamviewer-Cloud
geht.
Es gibt sogar einen Remote-Desktop
RDP-Server für
Linux.
Es gibt sogar ein paar
VLC, äh, warum sag ich immer VLC?
VNC
Clients, die so rudimentäre
Beschleunigungen haben und sowas.
Man muss sagen, grafisch ist unter Linux halt
an vielen Stellen ein bisschen Baustelle.
Also, jetzt wirklich
was im Sinne
von, ähm, diesem
neuen, ähm, 3D-beschleunigten
Remote-Desktop, was die eingeführt haben
mit, ich glaube, Windows Server
2008, wo du quasi
Grafikkarten direkt
über RDP irgendwie weiterleiten
kannst, die 3D-Ausgaben und sowas.
Sowas kenne ich unter Linux nicht.
Ähm, das brauchen wir aber eigentlich auch nur in den Sonne.
In den Ausnahmefällen.
Ja, also
grafische
Sachen unter Linux ist
an manchen Stellen kommt es
da schon noch ein bisschen vor, wie so
2005 oder so.
Aber wenn du
ein Linux-System administrieren willst,
da gibt es eigentlich eh nur
Konsole und SSH.
Das ist das einzig wahre.
Und in
dem Gesichtspunkt
funktioniert es
besser als Windows.
Weil, du hast nichts vergleichbares.
Und ich glaube, mittlerweile hat Windows
Windows, ähm, Windows 10
1903, also
das letzte, hat glaube ich mittlerweile
sogar einen SSH-Server.
Aber es könnte sein, dass der nur mit WSL
funktioniert, weiß ich nicht.
Aber, äh, Remote-Administration ist mit Linux
an sich deutlich einfacher.
Halt wenn es nicht um grafische Sachen geht.
So, ähm, mit was fangen wir denn an?
Fangen wir mit dem an, was schön aussieht?
Oder fangen wir mit dem an, was
menschlicher aussieht und beliebter ist?
Damit was wollen wir anfangen?
Wollen wir uns zuerst Elementary OS angucken
oder wollen wir uns zuerst MX Linux angucken?
Linux braucht eigentlich
nur ein Terminal und ein Browser.
Ja, der Zodiac, da gebe ich dir recht.
Deswegen bin ich ja auch
persönlich Fan von i3WM als
Desktop.
Ähm,
Elementary MX?
Was nu?
Ähm, deswegen bin ich ja
persönlich auch ein Fan von i3WM.
Einfach weil es die leicht
gewichtigste Variante irgendwie ist.
Ähm, die sich gut bedienen
lässt, mit der man
die notwendigen
grafischen Programme verwenden kann.
Okay, fangen wir mit Elementary an.
Gut, ähm, dann machen wir die
VM hier mal aus.
Und laden uns Elementary OS
mal runter. Danke für die ganzen
Followers übrigens.
Elementary OS kaufen, das ist Chebat.
Das ist wieder Chebat.
Da gibt es irgendwo einen Knopf.
Da gibt es irgendwo einen Knopf, einfach so zum
Downloaden.
Wahrscheinlich muss man sagen, Benutzerdefiniert 0.
Haha, verfe...
Gott, ey, ist das bescheuert.
Das ist Chebat.
Huge brain, ey.
Okay, runterladen. Zack.
Bam.
So, das andere können wir auch gleich mal runterladen.
Oh, das ist eine hässliche Webseite.
Das ist mal eine Webseite,
die sieht wirklich aus wie von 2005.
Huge,
huge hässliche Webseite. Moin,
home well.
Download.
Wo ist, wo ist der Download-Link?
The fuck?
Was ist das?
Äh, Phoenix, das wird mir was bringen, ja.
Okay, ähm, wir brauchen,
wir brauchen einen anderen,
wir brauchen einen anderen Mirror
irgendwo her. Abbrechen. Wiederholen.
Wiederholen.
Geht das schneller?
Wow.
Wie oft fängt es noch an, runterzuladen?
Äh,
das ist ein bisschen langsam.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass es schon Probleme gibt,
den Crap überhaupt runterzuladen. Ähm,
kann man hier irgendwie...
Moment, wir probieren was anderes aus.
Wir
Adresse des Links gruppieren.
Wir gehen erstmal in unsere Linux-VM
und machen einen Download, der mehrere TCP-Connections
verwendet. Vielleicht ge...
Was jetzt?
Wow.
Hä?
Okay, was auch immer.
Äh, laden wir es mal so runter.
Vielleicht geht das ja schneller.
Aha! Warum lädt das unter Linux
so viel schneller runter als unter Windows?
Vielleicht bin ich jetzt einfach, wurde ich einfach
auf einen anderen Server gebalanced oder so.
Moment.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt flutscht's
hier. Jetzt flutscht's.
10, 10 MB
die Sekunde, ist okay.
Was ist MIP? Mibibyte, ne?
Mibibyte.
Warum ist das so? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich vermute mal, weil ich auf einen anderen Mirror
oder ich, ich, ich vermute mal,
hinter dieser Uhr stehen wahrscheinlich irgendwie
50 Server oder so und
ich bin jetzt grad halt auf was anderem
gelandet, was schneller ist.
Ach, Mibibyte, es ist ja nicht Mibibyte.
Benutzt das wirklich jemand?
Man in
Black. Haha.
Das find ich gut.
10 Man in Black.
Kannst du auch mit DPD-Tracking
nur was anfangen? Ja, klar.
Ich brauch von OPS,
DPD, DHL,
Hermes.
Das sind die Sachen, die ich unterstützen will.
Und eventuell nen
Amazon-Tracking-Link.
Sofern man da nicht Adresse sieht oder so, dann zeig ich
das nicht im Stream.
Die Schreibweise geht in F-Disk. Ja, okay, aber
benutzt das wirklich irgendjemand?
Ich hab glaub ich bei mir auf der Arbeit noch nicht einmal
jemand Mibibyte sagen gehört.
Da sagen
alle immer, manche sind
sogar so faul und sagen nur M.
100 M.
Das ist dann voll
der Interpretation des Zuhörers
überlassen, was es jetzt eigentlich ist.
Ja, gib mal 100 M.
Oder, oder, oder, oder,
ich brauch 50 G. 50 G
ist eh immer das Beste.
Gut, ich mein, der meint Gigabyte, schon klar,
ja, aber das ist dann
die ganz kurze Variante.
Gib mal 150.
50 G.
Was, was, G?
Erdanziehung, oder was?
Flow geht mir genauso. Ich hab mir das auch mal als das,
als ich
damals, ja, schon, schon wieder,
als ich mir das mal durchgelesen hab, dass
eigentlich, ähm,
die Sachen mit Mibibyten
so viel, viel, viel korrekter
ist, eigentlich viel genauer,
hab ich mir auch immer vorgenommen, ey, du sagst jetzt
mehr Mibibyte und so, ich mach das auch nie.
Ja, ein Kibibyte, genau, gibt's
auch noch alles. Dann hätte ich hier die Tracking-Link
Nummer Z, klar, das ist, dankeschön, nice.
Schreib ich mir gleich auf.
Dann können wir nämlich im nächsten Stream,
wie alt sind denn die Tracking-Nummern? Wie gesagt,
ähm, UPS hat bloß
120 Tage,
120 Tage, ähm,
was gespeichert?
Die sind noch,
okay, dann machen wir, dann machen wir das im nächsten
Stream. So, also, wir haben runtergeladen.
So, und jetzt
müssen wir erst einmal das ISO,
was wir runtergeladen haben, transferieren
auf unsere Windows-Karte.
Kiste, das geht ganz einfach. Kann man nämlich einfach tracken
und droppen. Das ist auch was, was
mit, äh, vor allem bei Workstation funktioniert,
wo, glaube ich, VirtualBox
bis heute so seine Probleme hat.
Also man einfach tracken und droppen kann.
So, jetzt haben wir kopiert.
Das ist
sehr nice, dass das funktioniert.
Felix, dankeschön, schreib ich mir auch auf.
Was war das, DHL?
Track und droppen, ja.
Track droppen halt.
Warum, warum denn ISO
hier, äh, äh,
atommäßig ist? Keine Ahnung.
Weil Icons und so.
So, dann löschen wir das nämlich mal wieder.
Ach, ich hab's doch grad schon gelöscht.
Manchmal bin ich echt bescheuert.
Und den
Trash emptien. Okay,
dann haben wir, dann ist das schon mal erledigt.
Dann können wir jetzt, können wir uns
das Ganze mal angucken. Ähm, so,
und das andere, was wir downloaden wollen, war
das hier.
Wenn ich jetzt noch den Download-Link finde.
One of the official mirrors.
Äh, von
da. Fuck.
Von da.
FunkfreundeLanzhut.de
Ah, sehr interessant.
Von den Funkfreunden
Lanzhut wollte ich mir schon immer mal was runterladen.
Wirkt halt auch sehr
vertrauenswürdig, die Funkfreunde
Lanzhut.
Pff.
Wir könnten jetzt, wir könnten jetzt den offiziellen,
wir könnten jetzt den Hash-Wert überprüfen,
ob das, ob das stimmt.
Können wir machen.
Können wir aber einfach sein lassen.
Ja, das denk ich mir auch, user-friendly ist was anderes,
ne? Ähm, Moment,
wo war's denn hier? Wo waren die Funkfreunde Lanzhut?
Da. Was nennt man
hier?
Ah. Benutzerfreundlich wär gewesen,
sie machen einen Download-Link und
dahinter wählt
irgendwie einer random halt einen Mirror aus.
Oh, ich hab immer noch meinen
PPGA-Board gar nicht gestartet, das muss ich doch
machen. Deswegen krieg ich auch
die ganzen Chat-Nachrichten nicht mit.
Was ist denn das hier heute?
Hallo? Hallo?
Windows,
please!
Come on, bruh. Windows.
Was ist da schon wieder los, ey?
Geht wieder. Wenn ich jetzt hier rüber switche...
Ah!
Jetzt funktioniert's.
Irgendwie hat meine VM...
Meine...
Fuck.
The fuck, was jetzt?
Ich glaub, meine VM hat den Abgang gemacht, ey.
Grip. Nichts funktioniert
gerade. Die VM hat den Geist aufge... Da ist sie wieder!
Easy. Weiß auch nicht, was
der für Schmerzen hat.
So, ich muss nämlich noch meinen Chat-Log starten.
Äh, Moment, seht ihr?
Seht ihr überhaupt was?
Oder ist bei euch immer noch schwarz?
Ach, ihr seht nix!
Jetzt seht ihr wieder was, ne?
Cute Chat.
Das reicht ja auch, wenn man den Chat sieht.
Cute Chat ist das einzige, was man sehen muss.
Ja, ja. Da fällt mir ja gerade
dieser tolle Witz ein.
Äh...
Wo ist er denn?
Wo ist er denn? Ich find noch nicht...
Ah, hier! Ja.
Why does bison live on land?
Because it's above sea level.
Ich geb zu, es gibt Lustigeres.
Obwohl, ich find's lustig.
Das ist schon so dumm, ey.
Dead Jokes, ja.
Das sind nicht Dead Jokes, das sind
Dead Jokes.
Die sind ja auch schon uralt.
Ich find sie trotzdem lustig.
So, läuft der Kram jetzt?
Geht jetzt mein Chat-Log?
Mein Chat-Log geht.
Also alles, was ihr bisher an mich
geschrieben habt und was ich noch nicht beantwortet habe,
werde ich jetzt übersehen.
Aber ich scroll mal kurz den Chat hoch.
Ich glaube, da war nix mehr drinne.
Ja, das war klar, jetzt muss ich wieder ausprobieren.
Hermes!
Oh, Mirikari, dankeschön, nice.
Hermes-Tracking-Nummer ist gut.
Da kann ich das nämlich ausprobieren.
Sehr nice.
Dann haben wir fast alles
zum Ausprobieren für den nächsten Stream.
Warum gibt es immer noch keinen Pepega?
Doch gibt's doch, oder?
Hab ich ernsthaft noch nicht in Chat hinzugefügt?
Kein?
Kein Pepega im Chat?
Wirklich nicht?
Oh je, dann füg ich's gleich hinzu.
Seh ich ein.
Das ist essentiell wichtig.
Gleich hier.
Pepega. Zack.
Add to Channel.
So, ist drinne.
Ähm.
Ihr müsst refreshen.
Und wenn ihr
bei der Twitch-TV
verwendet, dann
dauert's nen Tag, bis das drinne ist,
das Emote. Wer FFZ verwendet,
sollte das Emote gleich schon sehen.
Ich könnte übrigens mal hier
rechnen, fällt mir grad ein.
Ich hab's ja schon runtergeladen.
Muss ja nicht 20 mal runterladen.
Okay, wie viel Plattenplatz haben wir noch?
81G. Perfekt.
Dann legen wir mal ne neue VM an.
Und
installieren mal Elementary OS.
Das ist ne Linux-Distribution,
die unglaublich beliebt war
vor ein paar Jahren. Die hatte nen riesen Hype,
weil's eine der
Linux-Distributionen ist,
die ein halbwegs
konsistentes
eine halbwegs konsistente Optik
haben.
Sowas ist für Linux-Distributionen
schon ein absolutes Highlight.
Es sieht nicht alles aus wie
zusammengewürfelter Shit. Oh mein Gott!
Unglaublich, dass sowas funktioniert!
Da waren sie alle voll mindblown
vor ein paar Jahren.
Mittlerweile hat sich das aber wieder gesetzt,
weil denen ihr Release-Zyklus ziemlich langsam ist.
Aber wir gucken uns das Ganze trotzdem mal an.
Soll angeblich ne richtig gute Einsteiger-Distribution sein.
Warum sind so viele Tracking-Nummern unterwegs?
Neue? Achtung, Paket ist das.
Nee, wir wollen sowas selbst
programmieren im nächsten Stream.
Eigentlich diesen Stream schon.
Aber ich hatte keine Tracking-Nummern.
Ganz viel bestellen.
Ähm...
Okay, legen wir mal noch VM an.
Installator.
Linux.
Und zwar wollen wir...
Ich glaube nicht, dass das hier drinsteht.
Wahrscheinlich steht hier kein Elementary oder so drinne.
Was ist VMWare Photon OS?
Oh!
ZClaros! Twitch Prime! Nice!
So, jetzt tut mir der Finger weh.
So, ähm...
Was zum Teufel ist Photon OS?
Was ist VMWare Photon OS?
Was ist dieses Twitch Prime?
Ja, wo du gerade Twitch Prime ansprichst,
bei dieser Gelegenheit kann ich es vielleicht
nochmal erwähnen. Wenn ihr einen Amazon Prime
Account habt, könnt ihr das Ganze kostenlos
mit eurem, Sekunde, passendes Emote,
könnt ihr das Ganze
kostenlos mit eurem Twitch Account
verknüpfen. Ihr bekommt im Monat
kostenloses Twitch Prime Loot.
Das ist das, wo es da oben die Krone in der
in der Titelleiste
gibt. Da, da oben, wo die Krone ist.
Prime Loot. Und ihr könnt
einen Streamer eurer Wahl mit einem
kostenlosen Sub unterstützen.
Der Streamer bekommt trotzdem die Kohle.
Euch kostet das Ganze nix.
So. Äh, was ist Photon OS?
Ah, ein
Container OS. Ich dachte schon, das hat
irgendwas mit, mit, äh, Valve
ihrem, ihrem Linux Zeug zu tun.
Ne, das war Proton, oder?
Proton? Photon?
Wow!
Flow 96. Hast Gehalt gekriegt.
Vier
Abos. Poggers.
Da, was, was mach ich jetzt hier?
Ich kann jetzt nicht nochmal
eine halbe Minute auf, auf Niceho klicken.
Oh, ne, das war, haha, falscher Knopf.
Aber, äh, sehr nice.
Flow 96, dankeschön. Vier
Subs. Und zwar gehen die Subs an
ähm
Ach, ne, sind drei
Subs. Ich hab mich, Twitch zeigt komische
Dinge an. Ähm
Lai Boomster.
Okay. Ähm
Alter Pommes
TV.
Wir haben wieder die besten Usernames
heute. Alter Pommes
TV und
Exposed Underscore.
Pog.
Ähm
Okay.
Jetzt machen wir mal weiter.
Also, wir können das nicht auswählen.
Elementor IS ist soweit. Ich weiß, basiert auf Ubuntu.
Deswegen wählen wir hier mal Ubuntu aus.
Next.
Ah ja, das passt da schon. Alles gut.
Zack. Number of Cores.
Das Ding kriegt zwei CPU Kerne. Das muss erstmal
reichen.
2 GB RAM ist auch okay. Wir haben
genug RAM.
Ach komm. Ach komm.
YOLO.
GG RAM. Dass der Scheiß auch ordentlich
flutscht. Ähm
Ja.
Ja. 20G.
Elementory.
Weiter.
Finish. So.
Dann benennen wir das mal um.
Dass ich das wieder finde nachher.
Elementory.
So. Und das
CD Laufwerk
schmeißen wir jetzt das ISO rein.
Ähm.
Ja.
Und dann gucken wir mal, wie es ausschaut.
Bin ja mal gespannt.
Angeblich die Linux Distribution,
die am besten ausschaut.
Und ähm
wohl das beste
Gesamtbild hat.
Also das einheitlichste
Gesamtbild. Gucken wir uns das Ganze mal an, wie das ausschaut.
Äh.
Leihbumster. Normalerweise benutze ich Manjaro.
Manjaro mit i3. Das ist sehr, sehr minimalistisch.
Okay. Wir haben schon mal
keine VMware Tools, wie es aussieht.
Das suckt.
Mit VMware Tools würde das nicht
so miniaturmäßig
aussehen. Sondern
bisschen größer.
Und worum es heute geht. Ich will mal absichtlich
die zwei
Distributionen ausprobieren, die angeblich
super für Einsteiger sind.
Weil mich ein Bekannter gefragt hat,
was ich ihm für eine, mal hier
Try Elementary.
Wir installieren gleich.
Installieren auf Englisch.
Jawoll. Install. Da können wir nämlich
auch gleich mal ausprobieren, wie einfach es ist
Keyboard Layout umzustellen.
Choose your Keyboard Layout.
Mich hat ein Bekannter gefragt, was ich ihm empfehlen würde
für eine Linux Distribution für Einsteiger, für eine Schule.
Ich hab halt so aus dem Bauch raus gesagt, hallo mach halt
Ubuntu drauf. Ja.
Ähm.
Wollt ich mal gucken, was es sonst noch so gibt.
Download Updates while installing
Elementary. Ok.
Ähm. Third Party Software for Graphics
Wifi Hardware
Ah ja. Mach.
Continue.
So. Jetzt sehen wir diesen tollen
640x480 Installer.
Moin. Der Patrick ist auch am Start.
Erased Disk. Install
Elementary. Jawoll. Install.
Alles gut.
20G.
Versteht nicht wie groß es ist allerdings. Ganz ehrlich.
Was soll passieren, ist nur vor allem.
Wir sind in Berlin.
Passt. Mein Name ist
Max. Max Virtual Machine.
Computer Name ist.
Max. Äh.
Computer Name.
Machen wir mal. Komm wir machen das
jetzt mal so. Dass die Leute wenigstens was von haben,
wenn sie subben. Der Flo96
hat so viele Subs
gespendet schon. Er hat jetzt schon
ähm. Schon 8 Abos verschenkt.
Das Ebaru hat auch ganz schön viele.
Unsere vor allem. Er heißt jetzt
Flo96.
Passwort 123456.
Beste Passwort aller Zeiten.
Require my password. Continue.
Das ist ein fair Passwort.
Easy Passwort 123456.
Endlich mal ein Installer
der 123456 als gutes Passwort
ansieht.
Da warte ich schon die ganze Zeit drauf.
Die sagen mir sonst. Die sagen mir alle sonst immer
das Passwort ist scheiße. Aber jetzt endlich.
Elementary OS weiß Bescheid.
123456. Beste Passwörter.
Hahaha.
Copy File.
Also das Ding sieht schon mal nicht so ganz einheitlich aus.
So und sobald das Ding
installiert ist, ist das erste
was wir machen müssen. Forever Tools
installieren. Weil ich habe keinen Bock
mir das Betriebssystem anzugucken
in 800x600.
800x600
ist mir im Jahr 2019 irgendwie nicht genug.
MrArmy
das stimmt. Und
das schreiben die sogar offiziell irgendwo.
Dass sie sehr stark von MacOS
inspiriert sind.
Ist installiert halbwegs geschwind. Ist ok.
Je nach VM dauert so eine Installation in der Regel
eh nicht länger als 5 Minuten.
Ich würde da schon von inspiriert
reden, weil ich meine ehrlich gesagt
es kopiert doch eh
was das angeht jeder von jedem.
Guckt euch das mal bei
irgendwelchen Games an. Da geht es doch
auch im Endeffekt darum, dass ein gutes Game rauskommt
und nicht ob irgendwie einer was was gut funktioniert
von einem übernommen hat
der es vielleicht vorher schon mal gemacht hat. Achso Moment.
Das Installen war noch gar nicht fertig.
Da gebatet.
Jetzt kommt das eigentlich installieren.
Ja Patrick das stimmt
und ich muss auch ehrlich sagen
so die ganzen Hardcore Linux Fanatiker
Achso irgendjemand hat vorhin
gefragt was ich für ein OS
auf der Arbeit verwende.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht wer es war.
Ist derjenige noch da?
Ist egal ob derjenige
ist egal weil
ich verwende das gleiche auf der Arbeit wie ich auch
privat verwende nämlich
Manjaro mit I3 WM
Manjaro I3 WM
ähm
Gnome Terminal drauf
Chrome als Browser
Chrome und Firefox als Browser
und natürlich Dark Theme
ja ganz wichtig.
Warum ist denn das so lahm?
Was ist denn das hier schon wieder 30 30
40 was
40 Minuten
für
für ein Paket ab...
okay es ist
es weiß noch nicht so genau was es will.
31 Minuten
ge ge ge ge gebatet
Moment da haben wir jetzt das passende Emote dafür.
Ja der ist leerer.
Was ist denn das?
Was machen die da?
Das liegt daran weil es den
deutschen Ubuntu Mirror verwendet
der ist bekannt dafür das er lahm ist.
Ich glaub wir überspringen das ganze mal.
Weißt du was? Dafür ist es doch ne VM
Wir können einfach das andere schon installieren.
Neue VM
Next
Workstation
Jaja wir installieren später. Linux
Ne wir nehmen wieder Ubuntu 64
weil letztendlich sind die Settings oder der Haube wahrscheinlich ziemlich wurscht.
Ubuntu 64
Virtual Machine Name
Was ist das? MX Linux
Number of course 2
Auch 4096
Woah
Bisschen viel RAM oder?
Warum ist MX zur Zeit auf
Distrowatch so beliebt?
Ja das versuche ich gerade rauszukriegen.
Ok
Bei der Gelegenheit können wir ein bisschen Zeugs
entfernen aus der VM.
Wir brauchen nämlich keinen Drucker.
Der Rest ist ok würde ich sagen.
Ok dann hängen wir als
ISO da hängen wir als ISO jetzt
Wo ist das CD Laufwerk?
Da hängen wir als ISO jetzt
das MX Linux dran.
Downloads
Ne wo hat er, wo hat er das
MX Linux hin?
Abgebrochen
Warum?
Muss das abgebrochen?
Wiederholen
Das lädt wenigstens ein bisschen schneller
Naja
Die Funkfreunde
Landshut sind nicht so schnell
glaube ich
Aber es geht rauf
Ok ich glaube wir müssen
Das kann doch nicht sein
Ich mein das ist mitten in der Woche
Warum dauert das so lang? Warum ist das so lang?
Wir suchen uns noch einen anderen Mirror raus
Was haben wir sonst noch für Mirrors zum
Downloaden?
Also
Das ist die umständlichste
Downloadseite die ich in den letzten paar
Jahren gesehen habe. Frankfurt!
Bam! Huge!
23media.com
Final
Snapshots Download
Ja das flutscht
wenigstens abbrechen
Das flutscht
Ja
10 MB die Sekunde
Lebst du mit der Telekom?
Ja
Ich streame gerade und lade über die Telekom
Weil heute morgen Unity Media abgekackt ist
Hab ich den Anschluss gewechselt
Also
Nicht gewechselt vertragsmäßig
Sondern umgestöpselt auf den zweiten Anschluss
Allerdings
Ist die Telekom demnächst Geschichte
Weil
Schonmal Deepin pro nutzt
Ja das ist das China Linux
Geschichte
Weil ich habe die Telefonnummer portiert
Zu Easy Bell
Das ist so ein recht günstiger VoIP Anbieter
Und ich hole mir
Von Unity Media dann
Den schnellsten Anschluss den es bei mir gibt
Das sind 40 40 40
MBit Up und 400 Down
Sofort die Abo bei Unity Media
Ne sogar umgedreht Telekom kommt weg
Und Unity Media wird Upgraded
Was ist eigentlich aus
Informatikor passiert?
Wieso?
Weil ich meine wir machen doch hier richtig
Informatikor Zeug
Gehen die Funkfreunde
Zufällig über Cognet
Keine Ahnung
Hast du schonmal einen tollen Namen
Davon
Könntest du theoretisch auch Unity Media
Für Unternehmen bei dir daheim abschließen?
Ja könnte ich machen
Die Sache ist bloß die
Dass du bei Unity Media Business
Quasi alles mögliche noch dazu kaufen musst
Also willst du Fernseher dazu
Wie war denn das?
Ich krieg das grad gar nicht mehr richtig zusammen
Also zumindest kostet das
Ungefähr das doppelte wenn du Unity Media Business hast
Du musst den Anschluss bezahlen
Du musst das Internet Zeug bezahlen
Und musst halt zusätzlich nochmal Fernseher holen
Ne genau genau
Du brauchst den Unity Media Business Anschluss
Der kostet dann irgendwie schon
Knapp so viel wie ich jetzt
Komplett bezahle
Und noch ein bisschen mehr
Dazu brauche ich dann wenn ich Fernseher gucken will
Einen normalen Kabelanschluss
Und halt
Irgendwie noch mein Grundgebiet
Es war zumindest so teuer das es sich nicht gelohnt hat
Zumal Unity Media mir ja auch versichert hat
Das es kein Problem ist
Wenn ich upgrade
Das mein IPv4 erhalten bleibt
Oder aber es alternativ einen vollwertigen
Dual Stack gibt
Damit bin ich zufrieden
Ok so
Virtual Box Video
MX start
Was macht eigentlich der Installer bei dem anderen
7 Minuten Remaining
Ok dann soll der mal weiter installieren
Wir installieren ja auch in der Zwischenzeit
MX booten
Sieht mir ein bisschen aus wie nach dem guten alten
Knoppix
Bootloader Ding
Das sieht ja aus wie 1995
Übrigens ich habe auch einen schwarzen Bildschirm
Das liegt nicht an euch
Da ist was
Ich sehe da was
Ah wir haben 1000
Wir haben 800 mal 600 wieder
Perfekt
Installer
Wir installieren erstmal
Und dann machen wir VMware Tools
Wenn wir VMware Tools installieren ist es ordentlich groß
Weil wisst ihr was wir machen können
Wir können noch um
Für die bessere User Experience
Können wir noch einstellen
View Stretch Guest
Hehehe
So
Next
20G Auto
Also der Installer ist relativ
Relativ übersichtlich und easy
Kann man nicht
Kann man nicht allzu viel verkehrt machen
Ja das ist auch ok
Formatieren wir alles
Was zum Teufel ist der PBR
Ich kenn
Ich kenn den MBR das ist der Master Boot Record
Ich kenn GPT
GPT
Das ist das was man bei neueren
Neueren Platten hat
Ist PBR
Und GPT das gleiche?
Und was ist ESP
EFI System Partition
Ah ok
Das ist das was man dann eigentlich bräuchte
Wenn man EFI bootet
Ehm
Next
Computer Name
Sibaro 96
Ne warte mal
Heißt der 96?
Heißt der Sibaro 96 und der Flo 96
Hinten dran
Kann das denn sein?
So viele 96
Samba Server
Ne
Sibaro 11 ist es genau
Nicht Sibaro
So
Zeitzone
Deutsch
Deutschland
Männlich Weiß Deutsch
System Clock Use
Local Format
Das da Time Zone
Berlin
Europe Berlin
Das hier ist der Installer
Schon ein bisschen umständlich
Old School
Aber ich finds gut das er installiert
Während man den Mist eingibt
U-Passwort
Hab ich auch kein Caps Lock drin?
Naja
Passwort Leak
Aufpassen
Ehm
Next
liegt da war ich doch aufpassen was man liegt alle klippen installiert oder auch
die drei drauf nie es geht doch gerade darum zu gucken was für eine
distribution sich gut für einsteiger eignet so wie sie kommt
also man spricht ja auch von der out of box experience im marketing jargon
remove installer disk kann man machen hat er schon
sondern das erste was wir machen müssen ist wir müssen vor allem tools
installieren es bietet ja drei stunden an die hat sie
bildet 123456 okay was auch immer wir müssen als erstes mal gucken wie meine
terminal reinkommen wie kriegt man hier den terminal muss
vor allem tools installieren der abmelden knopf der wichtigste knopf
der wichtigste knopf scheint der abmelden knopf zu sein so wie es aussieht
er hast du elemente schon getestet elemente installiert
gerade
der abmelden knopf ist das wichtigste das muss oben links sein dort wo man
instinktiv draufklickt oben links abmelden
wie wo hat man ist das hier ein startmenü terminal okay also nicht das
richtig ich habe ich habe eingestellt deutsch allerdings jetzt ist die
englische tastatur warum okay ab search vor allem wer wie heißt das auch open
vm tools oder so vm tools hieß das vm tools vm tool wie hieß der kram noch mal
vm tools open vm wir machen erst mal ein update wahrscheinlich ist es noch nicht
geladen okay wie stellt man die tastatur ein das ist auch okay es ist auf deutsch
das ist natürlich für mich jetzt schon mal grausam aber noobs wollen das wahrscheinlich auf deutsch
die tastatur einstellen tastenkürzel das system konfigurieren der systemtastatur muss da
gut für werden das wirklich so nicht ich will ich bin ich black bin für jetzt einfach auf deutsch
umstellen die konnte wie kommt man die tastatur auf deutsch umstellen
ich kann mir das immer nicht merken
wie hieß denn der kam auch
europa m tools
install open flks
Ja, ist es doch.
Hast du bei deiner Manjaro
VMKDE, Gnome oder XFCE
Manjaro genommen? Ich habe Manjaro
NetInstall genommen. Das ist das ohne alles.
Hast du eigentlich Interesse an
weiteren Mods auf deinem Discord?
Aktuell nicht. Ich glaube, wir haben nicht so viel, was
man moderieren muss gerade.
Es benehmen sich ja alle ordentlich.
Aber einen weiteren
Mod auf Twitch
könnte man tatsächlich gebrauchen. Das muss ich mir noch mal
überlegen. Ach, siehbar.
Du löscht was. Okay. So, und ist jetzt
gestartet.
Oh, ich mache das so selten. VM?
VM hat
CS-Control, muss man starten, ne?
Oder? Ne.
Äh, fuck.
Wie hieß der Kram, was man starten muss?
Wir rebooten mal. Das hilft bestimmt.
VM für User
hieß das doch irgendwie.
Reboot. Wir rebooten mal und gucken, ob
es dann
startet mit
ordentlicher Auflösung.
Stretch Guest.
Nope.
Wir stretchen nicht. Wir hoffen, dass es
jetzt ordentlich aussieht.
Okay, das hat... Das funktioniert schon mal nicht.
Okay, mal gucken, ob es jetzt...
Hm.
Gegen das OpenVM-Tools installieren. Und was musste man
danach noch mal starten?
Gar nichts, oder?
Du musst in der VM
die Auflösung einstellen? Ne.
Wenn ich VMware-Tools installiere,
geht das so. Ich mein,
wir können mal gucken, ob man überhaupt
die richtige Auflösung einstellen kann.
Display. Anzeige.
Guck mal, wir können doch nicht mal
1900...
1000...
1920x1080 kann man nicht mal auswählen.
Ne, ne, wir müssen die VMware-Tools
installieren. Abmelden.
Genau.
Hier ist... Ach, hier.
Kicker-Mail-Taste einstellen. Auf.
Ja. Englisch.
Cherokee. Englisch. Russisch.
Gibt's das?
Ich mein, ich hab's beim Installer
schon eingestellt.
Ähm...
Deutsch-Österreich.
Deutsch-Österreich gibt's auch...
Gibt's auch... Ist das normales
Deutsch? So nicht Deutsch-Österreich?
Dänisch?
Okay.
Das ist nicht anwenderfreundlich.
Deutsch-Österreich.
Okay.
Deutsch-Österreich. Meinetwegen.
Zuglück ist uns...
Ja.
Hm.
Ich muss mal gucken.
Debian-Display-VMware.
Was musste man da noch mal starten?
Open-VM-Tools?
Man musste Open-VM-Tools...
Da musste man irgendwas starten und dann ist es direkt...
Dann ist es direkt auf Fullscreen
geswitcht.
Allerdings mach ich das so selten, dass ich das...
Guck mal, Windows-Taste
ist richtig gemappt.
Schon mal ganz gut.
Vm.
Ich glaube, dass da musste man starten.
Was muss man installieren?
Was musste man installieren, dass man Fullscreen mit...
Wir könnten die offiziellen Vmware-Tools einfach installieren.
Einfach mal rebooten auf Vmware-Tool installieren.
Das haben wir doch gemacht.
Das Ding.
Was macht das jetzt?
Es läuft.
Das ist ein Debian-Troner, das weiß ich.
Vmware-Tools Fullscreen.
Was muss man da noch mal installieren?
After install you don't...
You can do this.
Nein.
Das bestimmt nicht.
Ja, das ist...
Das ist beknackt.
Ich meine, ich kann die offiziellen Tools installieren,
aber wozu?
Das muss doch auch so funktionieren.
Das da, genau.
Den Kram muss man installieren.
Da kann ich mich nämlich auch dran erinnern.
Das packt nämlich jedes Mal rum.
Das packt jedes Mal rum.
Zumindest hat das recht.
Unter Artstellung war das auch so.
Ja.
Den...
Moment, ist installiert.
Okay, wir installieren die offiziellen Vmware-Tools.
Weißt du, ne?
Das ist eigentlich, was funktioniert, ne?
Hast du in den Settings der Vm gesagt, dass er einen Monitor haben soll oder dass er sich dem Host anpasst?
Das muss man doch in Settings nicht sagen.
Display auto detect.
Use host settings for monitor.
Das ist...
Okay, so.
Das funktioniert.
Wir installieren, wir installieren jetzt einfach mal die, die offiziellen Vmware-Tools, äh, install Vmware-Tools, jup.
Können wir auch gleich mal gucken, wie noob-freundlich das ist.
Ich habe jetzt eine CD eingelegt.
Ich habe jetzt eine CD eingelegt mit Vmware-Tools.
Da ist es.
Okay.
Und wie kriege ich das, wie kriege ich das jetzt installiert?
Terminal?
Das muss ich wahrscheinlich...
Ich sehe nichts.
Okay.
Media, Media, Max, Vmware-Tools, Vm...
Ich sehe nichts.
So, und jetzt muss man irgendwie den...
Was muss ich denn ausführen?
Was muss ich denn davon ausführen?
Okay, wahrscheinlich muss ich, ich muss wahrscheinlich einfach mal darunter kopieren.
Das ist schon wieder hoch, hoch advanced.
Okay.
Enttarnen das Ganze.
Mit diesem riesen Terminal.
Max, Open VM Tools Desktop installieren.
Aha, da gibt es mehrere.
Open.
Huge Terminal.
Open VM Tools Desktop.
Ach.
Poggers.
Das muss man auch erstmal wissen.
Früher war das einfach Open VM Tools installieren, gut war.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist mittlerweile nicht mehr alles dabei.
Und wahrscheinlich habe ich deswegen auch nicht den Befehl gefunden, den ich die ganze Zeit gesucht habe.
Das ist Massive Terminal.
Gibt es Tap Completion für Abt?
Ja.
Hast du gerade gesehen.
Also ich habe es gerade hier oben gemacht.
Guck, ich habe hier eingegeben Open4M Tools.
Tap, tap.
Zack.
Wann kommt wieder ein neues Video auf deinen YouTube-Kanal?
Sobald mir YouTube nicht mehr auf den Keks geht.
Okay, und jetzt starten wir mal neu.
Ne, da ist er doch.
Jetzt gibt es gleich Vollbild.
M.
Eats.
Danach habe ich gesucht die ganze Zeit.
Hold Screen.
Warum hat sich meine Tastatur schon wieder umgestellt?
Okay, also.
Wie stellen wir jetzt hier die Tastatur ein?
Man muss ja die Tastatur...
Okay, also Windows-Taste funktioniert schon mal.
Das finde ich ganz gut.
Ähm, Zubehör.
Wie, wie...
Also mal angenommen wir sind jetzt...
Mal angenommen wir sind jetzt ein richtiger Noob.
Und können das nicht auf der Kommandozeile.
Ähm...
4M Tools D habe ich schon versucht zu starten.
Das hat allein nicht gereicht.
Man muss das hier starten.
Diesen...
Diesen User...
Das da muss man starten.
Das habe ich aber eben ums Verrecken nicht gefunden.
Entweder war es nicht da oder ich habe es nicht gesehen.
Aber ich glaube das war nicht da.
Okay, ähm...
Wir sind jetzt ein Noob.
Also wir gehen jetzt da hin.
Wir sind nur ein Noob.
Wir sind Leute, die sich prinzipiell für Technik interessieren.
So, und jetzt wollen wir einstellen Tastatursprache.
System.
Und dann...
Also ich sehe schon mal nichts von Tastatur.
Tastatur.
Einstellung.
Ah.
Druckeinstellung haben wir schon mal.
Keyboard Layout.
Schon geil, oder?
Das ist alles auf Deutsch.
Aber das ist auf Englisch.
Und warum muss das...
Warum muss ich root werden dazu?
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Da muss doch noch ein anderes...
Ey, es ist...
Also das ist schon auf jeden Fall nicht so einsteigerfreundlich.
Ähm...
Was macht...
Was macht eigentlich unsere Elementary Installation?
Hui!
Completed.
Pog.
Restart.
Okay.
Einstellung.
Moment, wo ist das?
Keyboard?
Keyboard Layout.
Schreibtisch.
Systemtastatur.
Tastatur.
Da?
Ah.
Das ist schon ein bisschen umständlich, oder?
Deutsch.
Nur Grave und Akkuzeichen.
Ich verwende immer No Dead Keys.
Was ist No Dead Keys auf Deutsch?
Keine...
Keine Todtasten.
Okay, jetzt ist es auf Deutsch, hä?
Ist es auf Deutsch?
Ey, es ist auf Deutsch.
Pog.
Okay, funktioniert.
Also, was haben wir denn hier schön?
Was ist das für ein Terminal?
Das ist...
Ich bin jetzt...
Das ist übrigens gar nicht mal so gelogen, ne?
Ich bin zwar kein Linux-Noob,
aber ich bin ein Noob, was Desktops angeht unter Linux.
Absoluter Huge...
Huge Noob.
Was ist da oben?
Skunky.
Oder sowas.
Ich bin ein richtiger Noob, was Desktops angeht, weil...
Ich verwende immer i3.
Das ist...
Das ist ja im Prinzip...
Das...
Das leichtgewichtigste, was du haben kannst auf dem X-Server drauf.
Das hat die ganzen Settings-Menüs nicht.
Okay, was ist das für ein Terminal?
Ist das ein Gnome-Terminal, hä?
Das ist ein ganz normales Gnome-Terminal.
Über...
Ah, ein XFCE-Terminal.
Okay.
Das ist auch ganz okay.
Haben wir ordentliche Schriftarten?
Haben wir Hack?
Hack.
Wichtigste Schriftart.
Haben wir nicht.
Transparenter Hintergrund.
Ihr Fensterverwalt...
Ihre Fensterverwaltung...
Leider unterstützt Ihre Fensterverwaltung kein Komposite.
Deckern.
Ähm.
Sollte es eigentlich...
Weil wir haben 3D.
Wir machen mal Power-Off.
Wir gucken mal, ob wir 3D-Beschleunigung für die VM eingestellt haben.
Probieren wir mal aus.
Der Matt schreibt, meine letzte Empfehlung wäre Mint oder PopOS Manjaro.
Das können wir tatsächlich auch mal ausprobieren.
Ich hab mir gedacht, wir können das eh ab und zu mal machen.
Und einfach mal angucken, wenn es, wenn es irgendwelche interessanten Linux-Distributionen gibt, neue Versionen oder überhaupt, können wir uns das einfach mal angucken.
Weil wir brauchen auch mal für den Stream so ein paar Sachen, die wir regelmäßig machen.
So aktuell ist es ja so, wir machen, wir machen im Prinzip jeden Stream was anderes.
Ähm.
Accelerated 3D-Graphics.
Haben wir schon eingestellt.
Okay.
Da wird nicht, da wird nicht kompostiert.
Und wenn nicht kompostiert wird, gibt es auch keinen Transparenter.
Das ist ja auch eine Art Probe-Sensorenz.
Du musst eh noch Proton testen, das kann ich in der VM nicht testen, gescheit.
Das müsste ich mal wirklich installieren.
Was wäre das Argument für PopOS?
Naja, wenn es ein Manjaro ist, spricht schon mal Manjaro dafür.
Ach ne, das müssen wir jetzt nicht mehr machen, weil wir haben es ja überschrieben.
Und er macht das automatisch nach dem Neustart.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Was sind das da unten für die, für die, für das CD-Laufwerk, hä?
Also, das ist eines der hässlichsten Start-Buttons, die ich lange nicht gesehen habe.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Mollygard nennt sich das, Bildschirmarbeiter, aber er hat kein Audio.
Okay, das ist für Paketupdates, okay, aktualisieren, ja, Rootpasswort, auch alles in Ordnung.
Okay, machen wir mal einen Browser auf in der Zwischenzeit und gucken was...
Das ist aber eine sehr rudimentäre Paketverwaltung, dass man im Terminal nochmal Yes klicken muss.
Aber ich glaube, das ist an sich eine recht leichtgewichtige Distribution, habe ich so den Eindruck.
Können wir mal gucken, es fühlt sich schnell an, auch in der VM, es verbraucht so gut wie kaum RAM.
Muss man immer mal nach dem Reboot gucken, weil mit der Zeit ist das dann...
Sieht immer so aus, als wäre es voll, auch wenn es gar nicht voll ist.
Aber es braucht 5 GB, krass, was ist denn da alles dabei, dass es 5 GB braucht?
Standard Instanz.
Standard Installation.
Was hältst du von Debian 10?
Ich habe Debian 10 noch nicht direkt installiert, ich habe nur das neue Raspbian installiert, was ja auch auf Buster basiert und da habe ich keine Probleme mit.
Okay, gucken wir mal, ob er meinen Stream anzeigen könnte.
Ich meine, es ruckelt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen.
Ja, funktioniert.
Machen wir mal die Qualität, volle Pulle.
Es ruckelt jetzt ein bisschen, weil es keine 3D-Beschleunigung hat.
Das ist jetzt Streamception hier.
Okay, das funktioniert.
YouTube.
So sieht also YouTube aus, wenn YouTube einen User nicht kennt.
Also im Prinzip die Ausgeburt dessen, was mich nicht interessiert.
Das ist ja ein paar Sachen, aber...
Okay, mal gucken, ob die Musik funktioniert.
Oder von...
Piss dich, Alter.
Okay, Sound funktioniert auch.
Ich habe schon wieder vergessen, wie schrecklich YouTube ohne...
Werbeblocker ist.
Sound funktioniert auch standardmäßig.
Ist okay.
Äh, das, was ist das?
Das ist Firefox, hä?
Ja.
Firefox.
Bäm, bäm.
Gleich mal, gleich mal AdBlogger installieren.
Ja.
Zack.
Jetzt gucken wir mal.
Ist jetzt Maxception wieder.
Oh, das, das, das kann er wahrscheinlich nicht.
Das ist zu viel.
Ein 4K-Video.
Ne.
Macht er nicht...
Oje.
Aber das ist...
Das liegt an der VM.
Also, das liegt an der VM.
Weil VM hat...
Du hast keinen Hardware-Decoder und keine Hardware-Beschleunigung und so.
Da ist ein 4K-Video schon ordentlich.
Oh jo, geht auch.
Und keine Werbung mehr.
Perfekt.
Der installiert im Hintergrund noch rum.
Was ist das hier?
Hä?
Was ist das?
Was macht der Knopf?
Ah, das ist ein Clipboard-Manager.
Das ist ein Clipboard-Manager.
Äh, Dome-PC.
Ich finde, das Ding hier sieht relativ, relativ ressourcensparend aus.
Aber generell ist es so, muss man sagen, wer, wer auf dem Notebook Linux installiert,
ähm,
der muss damit rechnen, dass die Akkulaufzeit ein bisschen kürzer ist als unter Windows.
Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel.
Ähm, umso älter der Notebook ist, umso besser supportet, kann es auch ähnlich gut oder vielleicht sogar besser sein.
Aber in der Regel ist es so, dass die...
Die ganzen, äh, advanceden Stromspar-Sachen, ähm, hauptsächlich unter Windows funktionieren.
Und unter Linux halt nur das, was standardisiert ist und was ordentlich auch beschrieben ist.
Wenn es da irgendwelche Hersteller, komische Firmware-Hacks machen für stromsparend,
dann funktioniert das meistens unter Linux nicht.
Ähm, ansonsten kann ich dir leider auch nicht sagen, was eine gute stromsparende Distribution ist.
So.
Also, mir gefällt MXOS, so wie ich es bis jetzt gesehen habe,
irgendwie,
das wirkt irgendwie sehr zusammengestückelt, oder?
So eine typische, so eine typische Linux-Desktop-Distro,
die alles irgendwie ein bisschen zusammenwirft und
halt irgendwie geht.
Aber wirklich so in Verzückung
versetzt es mich jetzt nicht.
Ich meine, guckt mal, allein schon, dass es mich hier draufklickt
und dass es weiß, obwohl das eigentlich ein relativ dunkles Thema ist, ne?
Aber, mein Hintergrund ist relativ dunkel, die Leiste ist relativ dunkel,
Browser hingeben, Fenster-Dings ist dunkel,
Browser-Controls sind auch relativ dunkel,
dann hast du das hier, das ist halt übelst hell,
mit einem Icon-Theme, was jetzt finde ich auch nicht allzu schön dazu passt,
aber gut, ich meine, das ist Optik, das kann man bestimmt,
das kann man bestimmt, äh, umstellen.
Haben die eigene Config-Tools, MX-Werkzeuge, okay.
Das kann man da einstellen.
Snapshot?
Okay, das, das ist ganz, das ist, das ist ganz cool.
Snapshot, Snapshot direkt auf CD.
Das ist zum Beispiel was, was für die Schule auch nicht schlecht ist.
Richtest dir das System einmal so ein, wie es sein soll und machst eine Live-CD davon.
Das ist eigentlich ganz, ganz nice so.
Ähm, was kann man hier sonst noch einstellen?
Kann man irgendwas für die Optik einstellen?
Okay, es ist schon mal Standard, wenn ich installiere, dass man sein iPhone mounten kann.
Das ist schon mal ein Pluspunkt.
Videotreiberinstallation brauchen wir nicht.
Soundkartenauswahl brauchen wir auch nicht.
Kann man irgendwie die Optik, so verschiedene Farbschemen oder Schemas oder so, ähm, einstellen?
Geh mal im Startmenü, neben den ein, neben, neben dem Shutdown auf Einstellungen.
Ist das Shutdown?
Benutzer wechseln, Bildschirm schon Einstellungen.
Ah!
Ja, das ist das, das ist das normale, äh, XFCE Ubuntu Settings Menü.
Erscheinungsbild.
Das ist das Standard, das ist das Standard Gnome.
Es gibt anscheinend nur ein MX, äh, Linux MX.
Ah! Da sieht die Sache doch schon schöner aus.
Fassen aber die Icons nicht mal gut dazu.
Das ist das Standard Gnome-Farbschema.
Das sieht doch jetzt ganz okay aus.
Darkseam-Beste.
das ist doch einstellung für orange sind kalender orange kalender mini kalender
ok mit alt gedrückt halten fenster moven ist schon mal gut dass der staat
mäßig drin ist es wirkt aber trotzdem ein bisschen ein bisschen zusammen
gewürfelt irgendwie außerdem ist der download jutsch langsam also ich denke
man kann es benutzen aber so wirklich die vollendung des
desktop designs scheint mir nicht zu sein
ich glaube was wirklich der vorteil davon ist ist dass es relativ
leichtgewichtig ist also das könnte wirklich eine ziemlich ressourcensparende
distribution sein wenn xfc ist ein desktop der ist relativ relativ
genügsam und ich sehe jetzt hier auch nichts laufen was großartige ressourcen
verschwenden würde das heißt wenn man ein halbwegs aktuelles notebook hat und
sich damit oder weil wir eben jemand geschrieben hat im chat etwas älteres
notebook
dann kann man es tatsächlich mal damit ausprobieren
e mail client stimmt was haben wir da einst dabei mail was sprung zu herigen um
sie zu beseitigen um sie zu beseitigen es ist nur schlecht übersetzt oder es
ist ein game was ist das gut also mails gibt es anscheinend zur auswahl thunderbird was mit dem gnome standard farbschema gibt es zur auswahl thunderbird was mit dem gnome standard farbschema gibt es zur auswahl thunderbird was mit dem gnome standard farbschema
grausam ausschaut Sabis am start nikki 30
moment, wo haben wir es hier
ohne die funktioniert ein arduino projekt mittlerweile dann nicht so dass ich mich nicht merken würde was zuschauer schreiben das stimmt das ist recht es
könnte darin liegen dass der theme geändert haben wir ändern dass man wieder zurück das ist richtig
ich habe nicht das default theme
lassen wir mal
Gucken wir uns mal an, wie das mit dem Default-Theme aussieht.
Es sieht besser aus, aber halt nicht dark.
So ein Zwischending zwischen dark und nicht dark.
So ein Medium-Dark.
Es ist voll ungewohnt, wenn man gewöhnt ist, unter I3 Fenster zuzumachen mit einer Tastenkombination, wenn das da nicht funktioniert.
Mach mal Arc-Dark rein. Probieren wir mal aus.
Arc-Dark.
Das sieht hässlich aus.
Okay, wir starten es nochmal neu. Vielleicht muss man es neu starten.
Bäh.
Okay, vielleicht gibt es hier noch weitere Themes, die man installieren kann.
Zeig mal her.
Upsearch MX-17 ist das gerade.
Desktop-Defaults-Leite.
Scheint nicht.
Ich finde das gar nicht so schön.
Ich fand das halt übelst hässlich aus.
Der Download ist lahm.
Okay.
Also ich glaube...
Ich glaube, für Notebooks, die nicht so gut ausgestattet sind, ist das gar nicht schlecht.
Es ist nicht so schön zu bedienen, aber es funktioniert.
Weil das ist ja für Linux-Destribution, Desktop-Distribution auch schon mal was, dass der Kram überhaupt funktioniert.
Die Installation ist relativ einfach.
Es ist alles mögliche dabei, was man so braucht.
Es ist ein File-Explorer dabei.
Ein Dateimanager dabei.
Es ist ein Browser dabei.
Es ist ein E-Mail-Programm dabei.
Es ist...
Ich klicke das übrigens gerade an.
Rechner.
Ich klicke das gerade an.
Das geht nicht auf.
Achso, das kann man nur rechts anklicken.
Präsentationsmodus.
Energieverwaltungseinstellung.
Was?
Ach, das sind die Power-Settings.
Das ist ja...
Präsentationsmodus.
Okay, was auch immer.
Bisschen komisch.
Rechner.
Warum steht da Rechner dran?
cloth-channel.jsp
Ähm.
Lautstärkereinstellungen...
Ähm, der Draw fragt sich, wie er seine Excel zum Laufen kriegt.
Ja, das ist mit Sicherheit so.
Allerdings, es geht doch hier um hier ne Klasse...
Also, es geht ja auch um ne Klasse an der Schule.
Wo!
Ehhh.
Wo gerade ein bisschen Technik-Krams vermittelt werden soll.
Das heißt, da wäre das gar nicht so übel.
Ist comin bisschen was üb....
Man das aber dazu sagen.....
War elementary schon dran?
Nee, das ist installiertjgg gerade in der anderen VM.
Ähm.
Das ist der Lehrer auch nicht, der absolut Linux-Pro ist.
Aber ich glaube, der wird halt little bit faster.
damit klarkommen haben sonst aber man kann sein netzwerk sachen einstellen
das noch einmal ein clipboard manager das finde ich standardmäßig übrigens
ganz gut dass man den clipboard manager dabei hat was ist das für einer klippe
okay es ist alles soweit dabei warum das
abmelden so prominent da oben platziert ist weiß ich auch nicht ich meine zum
abmelden kann man auch das hier klicken das wäre das erste was ich
beispielsweise rausschmeißen würde und die paket manager ja gut den würde ich
da lassen weil der ploppt halt auf wenn es neue paketupdates gibt ansonsten
finde ich das startmenü nicht so super übersichtlich hat man alles dabei
internet haben wir auf firefox ein tool für modems im jahr 2009 10 ist das
natürlich ganz furchtbar wichtig dass man ein tool für modems dabei hat hex
chat online mit anderen menschen chatten na probieren wir mal aus
ach das sind eigentlich nur ein paar tipps
ioc client also sonst wettbewerber kein mensch mehr
okay das stimmt nicht sie an sich ist immer noch nice aber es werden immer
weniger es ist firefox und thunderbird habe
das okay transmission bitter and vermag kraft puntos multimedia was
haben ein paar oben an ebook reader gut
was hast du vor ist sie benutzt
Früher habe ich immer dieses Mirk-IRC-Zeug unter Windows verwendet, zu den Zeiten, wo man noch IRC verwendet hat.
Tja, Flo96, da hat zumindest mal einer mitgedacht.
Da hat einer BigBrain, Flo96.
Ups, ich will kalt nicht starten, ich wollte nur gucken, was drin ist.
Okay, das ganze LibreOffice-Zeug, was auch sonst.
OrangeKalender habe ich noch nie benutzt, keine Ahnung.
OrangeWeltzeit.
Kleiner geht es auch nicht, oder?
Was ich, ah doch, das ist ja ein mega hässliches Programm.
PDF-Geduld und so weiter, ich warte, okay, Standard, Einstellung, ist jetzt egal.
Entwicklung, was ist dabei? C++-Entwicklungsumgebung, ja, warum nicht, Icon-Inspector, okay.
Grafik ist dabei, GIMP, geliebt und gehasst, gleichermaßen.
Was zum Scannen, Image-Viewer.
Standard.
Es ist wenig dabei, das finde ich aber eher positiv als negativ.
Hast du den LibreOffice-Remote-Code-Execution-Bug auf Twitter gesehen?
Nö, nö, interessant.
Ha, das ist ja lustig.
Guck mal, äh, ja, was man mit LibreOffice machen kann.
Also anscheinend ist ein Python-Interpreter in LibreOffice drin.
Das ist erst gestern, ist das gepostet worden.
Ähm, LibreLogo, ist das Python wahrscheinlich, ja?
LibreLogo executes code internally translated to Python code and execute.
Run a mouse over event, open a calculator.
Ernsthaft?
Ich kann einfach, das ist jetzt nicht den Ernst, oder?
Ich kann einfach, ich kann einfach Python-Text reinschreiben, der dann ausgeführt wird?
Das ist ja, da würde ich ja noch nicht mal von einem, von einem Exploit, das ist ja ein, ein, ein, ein, ein,
offensichtlich Ployt.
Obvious Ployt.
Max, probier's mal aus.
Was muss man denn machen?
Run a mouse over event.
Okay.
A document with the following contents.
Okay, probieren wir mal aus.
Ähm, was ist das?
LibreWriter.
Äh, where run is a hyperlink, executing LibreLogo run.
Ach so.
Ah ja, okay, einfach, ja, gut.
dann ist es doch nicht so getan mit reinpasten
das muss, das muss ein
das muss ein Link sein
wobei das ja kein Ding ist, wenn ich ne
Datei geschickt bekomme, wie mach ich das
jetzt überhaupt, wie stell ich das hier überhaupt ein
ich find
lieb, ich find diese ganzen Office Programme
unglaublich
schlecht zu bedienen, wie mach ich jetzt hier überhaupt einen Link
hat da irgendjemand ne Ahnung, wie mach ich den Link
Format, Insert, Link
Hyperlink
Omega Link
und dann
Assign Macro
äh
tja
jetzt wüsste ich, wie das funktioniert
Omega Link
äh
schon gefixt, ja ich weiß halt nicht, ob es hier gefixt ist
Leute, ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung
wie ich das, wie ich das in
in LibreOffice einstelle
ich müsste jetzt irgendein Makro einfügen
im Prinzip ist das aber auch nix
ähm
außergewöhnliches
Wörtdokumente passiert das auch laufend
das heißt jetzt nicht, dass das gut ist oder so, dass das hier auch passiert
ähm
man kann halt ein Textdokument, man kriegt halt ein Textdokument geschickt
wo einer, der dieses
diesen Link hier richtig
äh
formatiert und richtig konfiguriert hat
und wenn man die
wenn man einfach nur die Maus drüber
macht, wird das ganze ausgeführt
das ist natürlich ziemlicher Müll
deswegen würde ich standardmäßig Makros ausschalten
brauch ich nicht mehr so viel
äh
kein Mensch
kaum einer verwendet Makros so wirklich in ihren
in seinen Office-Dokumenten
wenn man sich überlegt, wie viele
Angriffsmöglichkeiten
Makros in Office-Dokumenten bieten
und die meisten Office-Dokumente kommen ohne Probleme auch ohne Makros aus
ich kenn da ne Excel-File jetzt nicht, das stimmt
aber ich bin da eh der falsche für
weil
ihr wisst ja, ich verwende eh keine
keine Office-Programme
seit Jahren schon nicht mehr
und ich bin da eigentlich auch ganz happy mit
keiner braucht Office-Programme
also
das stimmt nicht
wenn ich von mir aus gehe
würde ich sagen, keiner braucht Office-Programme.
Natürlich brauchen Leute Office-Programme.
Was machst du denn anstelle?
Naja, ich bin eh da an sich, das einzige Office-Programm,
was eine Daseinsberechtigung hat, ist Excel oder Tabellenkalkulation,
so als quasi Programmierumgebung für Leute, die nicht programmieren können.
Das, was die meisten Leute zum größten Teil verwenden, ist die Textverarbeitung.
Das ist super easy.
Da nehme ich einfach einen Text-Editor und mache das als Markdown.
Das ist als Markdown-Rendern und gut ist.
Das ist dann total einfach.
Mache ich einen WIM auf oder einen VS-Code auf oder irgendwas auf,
Markdown-Rendern gut ist.
Für Präsentationen verwende ich mittlerweile auch ein Markdown-Programm,
was quasi PDFs generiert.
Da kannst du einfach PDFs durchklicken.
Das ist die einfachste Präsentationstechnik, die es gibt,
weil ob du Powerpoint-Slides hast, die dann irgendwie rumbacken
oder einfach einen PDF aufmachst im Fullscreen und einfach nur weiterklickst,
ist am besten.
Du hast halt nichts Interaktives in dem Sinn,
aber wenn man ehrlich ist, es braucht kein Mensch reinfahrenden Text
oder Audiosachen, die abgespielt werden oder so.
In der Regel sollte ja das halbwegs unterstützen, was du sagst.
Was machst du, wenn dir ein Kunde eine DocX schickt?
Dann sage ich, piss dich, Alter.
Nee, dann mache ich die mit LibreOffice auf.
Speichert doch eh jeder seine Powerpoint als PDF.
Nee, nee, die meisten Leute speichern ihre Powerpoint als,
was ist die Powerpoint-Endung?
Powerpoint.
Und wenn sie präsentieren müssen, fummeln sie erstmal Powerpoint auf,
machen den Präsentationsmodus auf und fuddeln dann da drin rum.
Das Problem habe ich nicht.
Ich exportiere das Ding als PDF.
Doppelklick, weil es ja meistens Windows-Rechner sind,
wo die...
wo die Beamer und die Sachen dran sind.
Dran, Doppelklick, Fullscreen, let's go.
Überhaupt kein Ding.
Das einfachste von der Welt, PDF-Präsentationen zu machen.
Besser als da ein Powerpoint rumzufuddeln.
Ja gut, das war's.
Mehr brauchen wir von Office nicht.
Manche Leute verwenden Outlook.
Outlook verwende ich nicht.
Ich verwende es zwangsmäßig auf der Arbeit.
Hat man da auch die Notizen drin?
Nee, habe ich nicht, aber dafür habe ich einen Zettel.
Habe ich einen Zettel?
Den lege ich hin, da kann ich draufgucken.
Ich bin eh da an sich, man braucht nicht viele Notizen.
Also wenn man eine Präsentation macht und da sich ordentlich darauf vorbereitet hat,
die auch schon ein paar Mal, am besten natürlich mit Leuten,
denen man gut auskommt, schon ein paar Mal erzählt hat,
dann fallen einem eh, während man da steht und erzählt,
fallen einem dann eh schon die Sachen ein,
die man quasi in der Vorbereitung auch immer gesagt hat.
Man muss es einfach nur, einfach nur fünf, sechs Mal machen.
Und für alles andere, wenn man nur wirklich Details braucht,
dann nimmst du einen Zettel mit.
Also ich brauche, ich wirklich, ich verwende seit 15 Jahren kein Powerpoint mehr.
Ich habe das nie vermisst.
Ich mache meine Präsentation, mache ich in Power, mache ich, oh fuck, nicht in Powerpoint,
mache ich, mache ich in Text, Markdown.
Ich mache sogar mittlerweile Emojis in meine Präsentation rein.
Da hat irgendwann mal einer erzählt so nach dem Motto, ah, das wäre nicht,
das wäre nicht irgendwie professionell und Business.
Oder so.
Aber ich finde, das ist gerade irgendwie so ein bisschen im Geisterzeit, ja.
Die letzte Präsentation, die ich gemacht habe, da war, was war drin?
Da war das Thinking Emoji drin.
Das Monocle Emoji war drin.
Und ich glaube, das Brain Emoji war drin.
Das Monocle und das Thinking Emoji war auf jeden Fall drin.
Ich glaube, am Ende hat man noch das Brain Emoji drin.
Ja, und da hat,
hat keiner, hat keiner was zugesagt.
Letztendlich ist wichtig, dass man sich selbst gut fühlt
bei der Präsentation, die man, die man zeigt.
Ja, ich weiß, es gibt welche, die haben Vorgaben, so nach dem Motto,
verwende die offizielle Firmenvorlage, Powerpoint-Vorlage für Präsentationen.
Aber je nachdem, was es ist,
finde ich es viel angenehmer, wenn man eine Präsentation hat,
wo man selbst irgendwie dahinter steht.
Und bei mir sind es einfach ein paar Folien mit ein bisschen Text drauf
und den Rest erzähle ich.
Äh, Timbo, klar, mit, mit, äh,
heißt das eigentlich Latex, Latech?
Ich glaube, Tech heißt das, ne?
Ähm,
kann man das auch machen, das ist aber nur Wissenschaft für sich.
Hast du schon mal, schon mal ein Meme verwendet in, in einer Präsentation?
Ja.
Und zwar das hier, und zwar das hier.
Und das hier.
Das war aber nix.
Das war aber nix, wo irgendwie irgendwelche höheren Management-Dudes dabei waren, ja.
Das da habe ich verwendet.
Und zwar ging es da um unser Ticketsystem.
Und zwar ging es da um unser Ticketsystem,
wo die Leute teilweise Screenshots reinposten.
Also die Leute, also, wisst ihr,
anstatt, dass jetzt irgendjemand diesen Text hier copy und pastet
und ins Ticketsystem reinhaut,
haben die Leute angefangen, davon Screenshots zu machen und sowas.
Wo ich mir gedacht habe,
Alter, was ist mit den Leuten los, ja?
Und da habe ich halt das hier genommen und habe irgendwas draufgeschrieben,
so sinngemäß, äh,
One does not simply, äh, type text
oder irgendwie sowas Dummes stand da drinnen.
Ja.
Am besten sind, wenn dann Leute hingehen und irgendwie in eine, in irgendeine Tabelle gehen,
sich Hostname und IPs raussuchen
und die dann Screenshotten und ins Ticket hängen und sowas.
Nein, mich betrifft es wenig, ich muss mich da nicht drum kümmern,
aber jedes Mal, wenn ich sowas sehe,
muss ich mir an den Kopf greifen.
So, wo sind wir denn jetzt stehen geblieben?
Genau, also, warum ich kein Office mehr verwende, habe ich erzählt.
Was ist denn sonst noch so in einem Office,
was ist denn sonst noch so in einem Office, äh, Office Suite dabei,
die man, was man, was man sonst noch so verwendet, weiß ich auch nicht.
Wie gesagt, Tabellenkalkulation ist das einzige, meiner Meinung nach,
was eine Daseinsberechtigung hat.
Sowas wie Access, das braucht wirklich kein Mensch.
Also hier Base oder so, das braucht wirklich echt,
also, der hat Kontrolle über sein Leben versorgen,
wer Access braucht.
Ähm, äh, Draw, da gibt's, glaub ich, nix, äh,
das ist so ein bisschen wie Visio, ähm, bloß, bloß anders.
Visio ist auch ein Tool, was noch beschränkt seine Daseinsberechtigung hat,
auch wenn ich's nicht mag.
Ach, Visio ist immer drin, okay.
Was macht Access überhaupt? Ja, das frage ich mich bis heute.
Hast du an der Uni letztens Punkte bekommen, da ich eigentlich,
weil ich ein PPM-Profil mit habe, das ist doch gut,
da hast du einen passenden Lernprofil.
Ja.
Eure Zeiterfassung läuft in Access, naja.
Das ist ja noch schlimmer als unsere Zeiterfassung.
Unsere Zeiterfassung läuft mit einer Software, die ist von 1995,
zumindest wenn man dem Copyright glaubt,
und funktioniert am besten im Internet Explorer.
Das ist kein Witz.
Ach, sie funktioniert.
OneNote, ja tatsächlich, OneNote hat seine Daseinsberechtigung,
gar keine Frage, das würde ich aber nicht zur klassischen Office-Anwendung zählen,
ja, und außerdem gibt's da Alternativen.
Manche schwören ja auf Evernote, mache ich nicht.
Was ich mache ist, Plaintext-Notizen gesynct einfach auf mehrere Systeme.
Markdown-Plaintext-Notizen, komme ich auch super mit klar.
Die advanced Features, wie beispielsweise irgendwelche Text-to-Speech-Geschichten
oder Webseiten-Snapshotten oder so alles, was OneNote kann, verwende ich nicht.
Plaintext-Notizen, beste.
Ja, so viel zum Thema Office-Programme.
Hydrogen, Jojo, das wundert mich nicht.
Zeiterfassungen sind teilweise so selbstgestrickte Ausgeburten der Hölle, ja,
die sich vor allem dann auch so tief in die Firma irgendwie reingegraben haben,
dass man die nie wieder rauskriegt.
Lexware, wusste ich gar nicht, dass es das noch gibt.
Guck mal, wie viel Scheiß in Office 365 drin ist.
Wenn ich ehrlich bin, keine Ahnung, was ist da mittlerweile alles drin.
Also wenn ich an Office denke, hallo, kannst du starten?
Wenn ich an Office denke, denke ich an Access, Outlook, Word, Excel, PowerPoint, fertig.
Das ist für mich so die Core-Bestandteile, äh Excel, falls ich es vergessen habe.
Was ist in Office 365 drin?
Office 365, was haben wir da alles drin?
Also, Outlook, OneDrive ist es, glaube ich.
Word, Excel, PowerPoint.
OneNote?
Ist das Skype?
Teams?
Und?
Ah, SharePoint, SharePoint.
Oh, Big Brain, Leute, ja.
Da seht ihr mal, wie gut ich mich damit auskenne.
Jammer.
Jammer?
Was zum Teufel ist Jammer?
Jammer, soziales Unternehmensnetzwerk.
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch bloß was, wo sich BWL-Management-Dudes glauben,
dass man sowas braucht, oder?
Sowas braucht doch kein Mensch.
Wozu braucht man sowas?
Ich trotz.
Kann ich mir vorstellen.
Okay, was soll immer das?
Also, das kann man mal vergessen. Teams ist ganz cool.
Also, besser als Slack auf jeden Fall.
Ähm.
Wobei ich persönlich, ihr wisst ja, ich bin bei sowas immer so ein bisschen...
Ich komme mir bei sowas immer so ein bisschen oldschool vor.
Ich bin immer auch der Ansicht, wenn man einen Chat braucht, der funktioniert,
und einfach nur einen Chat, nur einen Chat ohne irgendwas,
dann ist Jammer nicht schlecht.
Alles andere an Jammer ist Kacke.
Die ganzen Jammer-Erweiterungen sind unnötig kompliziert und unnötig schlecht.
Aber rein für Text ist Jammer ziemlich gut.
Alternativ kann man auch immer noch ISC verwenden.
Oder aber, wenn es wirklich was Advancedes sein muss,
dann kann ich mich mit Teams anfreunden.
Slack mag ich nicht.
Slack gefällt mir nicht.
Also, wenn ich die Auswahl hätte zwischen Slack und Teams, würde ich Teams nehmen.
Aber...
Das ist dann auch tatsächlich von allen Office-Programmen, die man hier gezeigt hat,
das einzige, was ich gerne verwenden würde.
Ja, Teams ist wirklich ganz nice.
Ich meine, wenn man sich aber mal überlegt, was der Vorgänger war, nämlich Skype for Business,
das ist ja gar kein Vergleich.
Skype for Business war einfach der ober-Crap-Bodensatz überhaupt.
Da ist Teams dagegen ja das gottgesandte Geschenk, wenn man gläubig ist.
Wenn man das vergleicht mit Skype for Business.
Ja, Lync ist das, genau, Skype for Business.
Das ist ja nicht das normale Skype, es heißt ja nur Skype,
aber mit Skype hat man nicht mal was zu tun.
Aber naja.
Das ist so...
Den Rest braucht man nicht.
Es gibt ja mittlerweile auch ein paar Alternativen.
Ein paar Open-Source-Alternativen für Slack.
Ich habe aber noch nichts davon ausprobiert.
Was gibt es denn da? Matrix? Gibt es da irgendwie Meta...
Nee, MetaMost war das? Riot?
Ah, ich kann es mir nicht merken.
Habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert, ob die was taugen.
Ehrlich gesagt, wisst ihr, was ich machen würde?
Wisst ihr, was ich machen würde?
Mal angenommen, ich hätte irgendwie so einen...
Super...
Also, mal angenommen, ich müsste mich wirklich um ein Team kümmern,
was aus so super agile, agilen Leuten halt um die Welt verteilt besteht.
Wisst ihr, was ich dann machen würde?
Dann würde ich einen Discord-Server erstellen.
Ohne Scheiß, ich würde einfach einen Discord-Server erstellen.
Und ich weiß, Discord ist nicht selbst gehostet.
Also, da leakst du potenziell irgendwelche Infos.
Aber man muss sich halt mal überlegen, für was man das verwendet, ja?
Wenn es da nicht gerade um systemkritische, geschäftskritische Dinger geht.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich einfach einen Discord installieren.
Also, nicht einen Discord-Server aufmachen dafür.
Dann hast du nämlich alles, was du brauchst, inklusive Remote-Access.
Inklusive Desktop-Übertragung.
Und ich würde auf diesen ganzen Office-Crap die Finger von weglassen.
Also, mit ich meine ich nicht so nach dem Motto,
ich würde und heißt sollen alle, sondern ich würde es weglassen.
Für mich.
Wenn jemand mit Office glücklich ist, ist das ja eine schöne Sache.
Und das ist auch sowas, was, finde ich,
vielen Hardcore-Linux-Fanatikern so ein bisschen abgeht.
Die tun sich unglaublich schwer, zu sagen oder zuzugeben,
dass Leute auch mit anderer Software glücklich sein können,
als die, die sie selber verwenden.
Weiß ich nicht, ob ihr das...
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr so Leute kennt.
So nach dem Motto,
wer Vim mit Arrow-Keys verwendet,
ist der Kack-Noob schlechthin.
Ja.
Und wer vielleicht sogar noch sagt,
ey, ich verwende lieber Visual Studio Code anstatt zu Vim,
da bist du komplett unten vorbei.
Untendurch, ja.
Die usen auch Arch, by the way.
Ja klar, Arch, by the way, ist das Wichtigste.
12, by the way und Mercy-Main auch noch.
Das sind Kombinationen.
Wenn du dann noch Arch verwendest, dann ist es komplett aus.
Also ich bin der Meinung, es soll jeder, die Software verwenden,
mit der er glücklich ist,
sollten das alle Seiten nicht so verbissen sehen, ja.
Timbo sagt, die sind bei uns auf die Idee gekommen,
dass Ticketsysteme über MS Dynamics 365 laufen.
Boah, jetzt geht es aber ab.
Wollen sie es aber wissen.
Und wenn du dann noch eine IDE benutzt,
dann bist du komplett unten durch.
IDE ist ja Plotware.
IDE ist, wer verwendet IDE ist.
Du kannst alles mit Seed machen.
Alles mit Seed.
Wer braucht schon Editor?
AWK Seed.
Echo.
Echo, AWK Seed.
Beste.
Alles.
Mehr brauchst du nicht.
Alles andere ist Plotware.
Es gibt Leute, die denken das wirklich so.
Die denken wirklich so.
Wir haben auch so ein paar Leute auf der Arbeit.
Die der Meinung sind, dass nur ihre Sache das einzig wahre ist.
Ich denke mir, es soll im Endeffekt jeder verwenden.
Er kann einfach benutzen, was er will.
Allerdings, und das sage ich den Leuten auch immer,
wenn es was ist, wo ich keinen Bock drauf habe,
dann supporte ich es nicht.
Also nicht auf der Arbeit, sondern privat.
Wenn ich da Geld für bekomme, ist mir das egal.
Wenn jetzt irgendwie einer mich fragt,
Max, was würdest du mir vorschlagen?
Was soll ich mir für...
Was schlägst du mir vor zu holen?
Was meinst du an Software?
Was schlägst du mir vor für den Fernseher?
Was auch immer.
Und wenn ich mich damit beschäftige und gebe einem dann eine Empfehlung
und wenn dann irgendjemand sagt, nee, ich kaufe mir doch was ganz anderes,
dann kann keiner verlangen, dass ich das Ganze supporte.
Man verlangen kann es eh keiner.
Aber ihr wisst, wie ich das meine.
Mein Opa beispielsweise damals hat gesagt,
was würdest du mir vorschlagen für den Fernseher zu holen?
Der hatte damals schon ein bisschen her,
hatte so seine komische Röhre damals.
Er wollte sich halt endlich mal einen neuen Fernseher kaufen.
Da habe ich ihm gesagt, ich gucke mal nach.
Was ist da was Gutes?
Da habe ich was richtig Gutes rausgesucht für ihn,
was auch mit dem Sitzabstand und alles gepasst hätte.
Und was hat er gemacht?
Er ist in den Mediamarkt gefahren
und hat sich von dort von denen irgendeinen Scheiß aufschwätzen lassen.
Wo ich mir auch gedacht habe, okay,
warum habe ich mir überhaupt Gedanken dazu gemacht, ne?
Gibt jetzt keinen Support mehr.
Und als das Ding das erste Mal rumgezickt hat,
bin ich hingefahren, habe mir das angeguckt,
habe gesagt, ja, du wolltest ja unbedingt einen anderen Fernseher kaufen,
als ich dir empfohlen habe.
Damit kenne ich mich jetzt leider nicht aus.
Da kannst du jetzt auch nicht mehr helfen,
wenn man den wieder in Gang kriegt.
Natürlich habe ich ihm trotzdem geholfen,
natürlich habe ich ihm trotzdem geholfen,
ja, aber er hat erst mal ein bisschen,
erst mal ein bisschen blöd geguckt.
Er hat gesagt, ah, stell dich doch nicht so an,
ah, nee, ich muss doch, muss doch,
was hat er immer geguckt?
Der Alte hat er immer geguckt.
Das lief dann, da war er, war er ganz toll.
Das heißt, das kann ich jetzt nicht gucken.
Das war für den ein halber Weltuntergang.
Und da habe ich es natürlich trotzdem gefixt.
Ich lag ja gar nicht am Fernseher,
sondern an seiner komischen DVB-T-Empfangsbox.
Der war ja auch ein bisschen
nicht so ganz auf dem Arsch.
Der hatte eine Dachantenne
und hat quasi bis zum bitteren Ende
hat er über Dachantenne analoges Fernsehempfang.
Und anstatt, dass er danach gesagt hätte,
ey, komm, wir machen jetzt Kabelanschluss
oder wir machen Satellit,
hat er dann DVB-T dran gemacht.
Und DVB-T hat halt geruckelt
und war übelster Crap.
Und damals habe ich auch gesagt zu ihm,
weißt du was?
Was hältst du denn davon,
wenn du das mal zum Anlass nimmst
und dir einen Kabelanschluss legen lässt?
Weil Satellitenschüssel wollte er nicht.
Weil Satellitenschüssel wollte er nicht haben,
weil das muss an die Hauswand dran und sowas.
Das geht ja nicht,
dass da eine Schüssel an der Hauswand hängt.
Wie wäre es denn mal,
wenn du das zum Anlass nimmst,
jetzt mal Kabelanschluss in den Keller legen zu lassen?
Weil der Witz ist ja gewesen,
damals, als die die ganze Straße aufgerissen haben
und quasi kostenlos jedes Haus angeschlossen haben,
hat mein Opa damals gesagt,
nee, so modernen Scheiß wie ein Kabelanschluss,
nee, sowas brauchen wir nicht
und ich lasse euch nicht in meinen Keller.
Und da haben die halt gesagt,
ja gut, dann schließen wir sie halt auch nicht an.
Und das ist ihm dann halt 20 Jahre später
jetzt zum Verhängnis geworden.
Da haben sie sich gedacht,
was heißt zum Verhängnis geworden?
Er konnte halt keinen Kabelanschluss kriegen.
Und dann hat er den sauren Apfel gebissen irgendwann,
nachdem DVB-T so beschissen war,
dass es überhaupt nicht richtig funktioniert hat,
auch mit seiner Dachantenne nicht,
hat er halt in den sauren Apfel beißen müssen,
sich an die Hauswand eine Satellitenschüssel zu hängen.
Pech gehabt.
Manchmal sollte man vielleicht auf die Leute hören,
die sich ein bisschen mit der Thematik auskennen.
Gut, sowas zum Thema Auskennen.
Wir gucken uns jetzt Elementary OS an.
Leute, die damals auf HD-DVD gesetzt haben.
Ja gut, das sind so Sachen, wo natürlich die Hersteller auch,
das sieht doch schon mal gleich viel hübscher aus, oder?
Viel Wert drauf gelegt haben, alles irgendwie anzupreisen.
Du weißt ja, das ist ja auch so ein bisschen das Problem,
du weißt ja manchmal als Noob gar nicht,
was jetzt was taugt und was nicht.
Der Heimautomatisierungs-Noob kauft sich ein fertiges Gerät
von Homematic oder Fritz Home Automation
und hat dann Probleme, dass seine Lampen nicht richtig
mit dem Thermostat und das Thermostat nicht richtig
mit den Fenstersensoren zusammenarbeiten.
Aber er hat sicher irgendeine proprietäre Lösung,
also hat er das Ding gekauft,
was nur eine Sache von einem Hersteller kann.
Aber der hat nicht dran gedacht.
So machen das halt die Noobs.
So, das sieht schon mal viel hübscher aus.
Viel, viel hübscher sieht das aus.
Terminal.
Ja, das sieht doch schon mal schicker aus.
Flow 690, hast du eigentlich gesehen,
wie das Betriebssystem heißt hier?
Achso, du warst ja schon da, als wir das installiert haben.
apt install open-vm-tools-desktop.
Wir wissen jetzt ja, wie es funktioniert.
Das Icon-Set ist nicht das beste.
Ich finde das eigentlich recht hübsch.
Ich finde das wirklich hübsch.
Okay, ähm...
Firmware...
User...
Achso, ich glaube, jetzt muss ich hier wieder einstellen,
dass das Stretch ausgeht.
Bam!
So easy kann es sein.
Okay, auf dem Desktop kann man keine Icons machen,
wie es aussieht, ne?
Wow!
Was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
Wie kriege ich das wieder hin?
Was habe ich da überhaupt gelöscht?
Ich habe das Internet gelöscht, ja.
Das ist doch...
Also optisch finde ich das sehr schick.
Mal schauen, ob wir das irgendwie mit 3D-Beschleunigung hinkriegen.
Ah, ist schon eingeschaltet, okay.
Guck mal, es hat gebimmelt da oben.
Update Center.
Das ist doch mal was ganz anderes.
Das ist wirklich eine sehr hübsche Oberfläche, muss ich sagen.
Also für Linux-Verhältnisse wirklich eine verdammt hübsche Oberfläche.
Update All.
Das ist auch super easy zu updaten.
Fenster Resize mit Windows-Taste, auch sehr schön.
Fenster verschieben mit Windows-Taste.
UI Bloated.
Ja, das ist jetzt relativ lahm,
weil ich halt keine 3D-Beschleunigung habe für den Desktop.
Was habe ich denn da gelöscht?
Ja, hat irgendjemand eine Ahnung, was ich da gerade gelöscht habe?
Mit Homematic habe ich nichts gemacht, ne.
Plutonan, das finde ich auch.
Du hast Leute, die keine Ahnung haben,
aber denken, sie haben Ahnung
und vor allem das dann auch noch anderen Leuten erzählen.
Die das dann glauben.
Und alles wird noch schlimmer.
Hat das jetzt schon geupdatet?
Ah, ne, das updatet noch.
Das ist GNOME.
Ja, klar, haben die nicht komplett die Oberfläche komplett selbst programmiert.
Das ist schon klar.
Aber das, wie es zusammenpasst und so, muss ich sagen,
ist wirklich sehr, sehr hübsch.
Das gefällt mir.
Gefällt mir gut.
Hat das jetzt geupdatet?
Das updatet noch.
Okay, Browser.
Was ist das für ein Browser?
Was ist denn das?
Ach, das ist der Standard-Gnome-Browser.
Den verwendet auch, den verwendet ja wirklich kein Mensch.
Wie heißt der denn?
Epiphanie.
Epiphanie?
Du hast die Multitasking-View gelöscht.
Okay, kriegt man die, kriegt man die Multitasking-View,
kriegt man die wieder hin?
Wow.
Multi?
Da ist sie wieder.
Jetzt weg.
Das mache ich nicht richtig.
Da ist sie wieder.
Flup, flup, flup, flup, flup, flup.
Flup.
Da ist die Multitasking-View wieder.
Das ist die Multitasking-View.
Ach, da ist so ein Exposed-Mode.
Wo es so rauszoomt.
Weiteren Desktop?
Videos?
Ja, das ist zum Desktop-Switchen hier.
Also, ich muss sagen, optisch ist das für den,
für eine Linux-Distribution wirklich sehr hübsch.
Ich meine, warum sie so einen komischen Crap-Browser da
standardmäßig dabei haben, weiß ich nicht, aber
unten drunter ist wahrscheinlich auch Webkit.
Was?
Joputubne.
The way.
Das klingt eher nach Ubuntu.
Ubantu.
Was mir nicht gefällt, ist das Fenster-Maximir mit diesem komischen,
komischen Ding da oben.
Ach, doppelt draufklicken geht auch.
Percy-Reaktion auf Lohn ist da.
Wer ist Percy?
YouTube Deutschland.
Die Schrift sieht nicht richtig geklettert aus.
Das ist schon mal Crap.
Moment, wenn man die Windows-Taste drückt,
geht ein Keyboard, geht ein Shortcuts-Menü auf.
Windows-Taste und Space.
Windows-Taste und Space öffnet das.
Anti-Font.
Oh, es macht sogar Sounds, wenn man zu viel eintippt.
Kennt ihr mal ein gutes Tool, mit dem ich Präsentationen in Markdown
schreiben kann? Kann ich dir gleich eins raussuchen.
Also, ich kann dir das raussuchen, was ich auch verwende,
wenn ich es auf GitHub finde.
Da kannst du Streamer pranken mit.
Wie sieht der File-Browser aus?
Das ist normaler Nautilus, ne? Wow.
Das ist normaler, normaler Nautilus hier.
HackMD.
Könnte sogar sein, was ich meine.
Ne.
Warte mal, ich sagte...
Wie hieß das denn?
Nein, nein, das ist es nicht.
Remark? Könnte das sein?
Marp! Marp ist es, was ich verwende, genau.
Das verwende ich.
Für Markdown-Presentations.
Ich meine, hat 8000 Scheren auf GitHub?
Okay, hier gibt es anscheinend was Neues, was auch immer.
Es ist halt eine Elektron-Anwendung, was aber okay ist.
Das verwende ich. Das finde ich gut.
Da kannst du...
Da hast du ja auch neben deinen Slides.
Wir könnten das mal installieren.
Da können wir doch gleich mal gucken, wie man hier was installiert.
Es ist für mich übel schwer, sowas zu bedienen,
weil ich bin einfach meine...
Meine Shortcuts von i3 gewöhnt.
Machen wir ein Terminal nochmal auf.
Die Schrift machen wir ein bisschen größer.
Das ist zu klein.
Ich finde es aber auch...
Ich finde es super, wie die das gemacht haben.
Guck mal.
Du hast das Settings-Menü sogar überall an der gleichen Stelle und sowas.
Davon könnten sich generell mal grafische Linux-Programme was von abschneiden.
Ja, und Schriftgröße lässt sich auch einfach anpassen.
Wie man den Font ändert, ist mir nicht ganz klar.
Öh.
Wo kann man die aktuelle Version downloaden?
Ah.
Release ist 0.
Okay, es scheint übelst kompliziert zu sein, das runterzuladen.
Okay, das...
Man nimmt noch die alte Version.
Die sind mit der anderen noch nicht so weit.
Okay, Releases...
Das ist ja wirklich outdated.
Gibt es da nicht schon irgendwas Neues?
Ja, laden wir mal runter.
Ist ja egal.
Ist ein Präsentationsprogramm.
Man muss echt sagen, schön gemacht ist die Oberfläche allemal.
Okay, so schaltet man zwischen den Desktops um.
Das finde ich schon mal richtig gut.
Da kann man nämlich einfach auf dem zweiten Desktop ein Terminal ausführen.
Im Fullscreen.
Das finde ich schon mal sehr praktisch.
Das gefällt mir.
Terminal im Fullscreen ausführen, einfach zwischen Desktop und Browser...
Zwischen Browser und Terminal hin und her schalten.
Das ist sehr schick.
Finde ich gut, dass das standardmäßig schon gemappt ist.
Oh.
Okay, aus irgendwelchen Gründen läuft der Scheiß nicht.
Das ist natürlich schlecht.
Dass das einfach nicht funktioniert.
Wo wir wieder bei Linux-Dingen sind.
Als Schüler kann man Multi-Desktop missbrauchen, um heimlich irgendwelche Sachen zu machen.
Ja.
Ich will ja gar nicht die Web-App.
Ich will...
Ich meine, ich kann mal die Web-App probieren, aber es sollte eigentlich ein ordentliches Desktop-Programm geben.
Was war das hier?
web.map.app
Ah ja gut, ist ja im Prinzip sowas.
Ne?
Genau.
Das ist ähnlich wie das Desktop-Programm.
Also das ist das, womit ich meine Präsentation mache.
Kannst du hier schreiben, so machst du dich...
Hallo...
Cute Chat.
Dann machst du so für neue Seite...
Ne, fuck.
Äh.
Moment, wie wir neue Folien machen?
Ich habe vergessen, wie man neue Folien macht.
Wie kriegen das nochmal neue Folien?
Äh.
War das...
War das doch früher mit Minus, Minus?
Minus, Minus, Minus?
Ah.
Ja.
Fast.
Ich war...
Es war nicht...
Das ist E-Mail-Signaturen.
Ich habe es durcheinander gebracht.
Das ist...
Das ist Oldschool-Endung für E-Mail-Signaturen.
Und neue Seite.
War das da genau?
Ja.
Also hier...
Hallo, Cute Chat.
Und dann kann man jetzt sagen...
Ah ja, ja.
Das ist...
Das ist Oldschool-Endung für E-Mail-Signaturen.
Und neue Seite.
War das da genau?
Ja.
Also hier...
Das ist Oldschool-Endung für E-Mail-Signaturen.
Und neue Seite.
Ah ja, ja.
Früher...
Die hatten doch in der alten Version ja auch ein Icon für Images einfügen.
Ah ja, ja.
Auf...
Geh auf.
Seite.
Hier Emoji.
Oh!
Kein...
Kein Emoji Support im Browser.
Da ist das schlecht.
Irgendwie lädt das alles nicht.
Oh.
Das...
Das ist schon mal nicht gut.
Kein Emoji Support.
Standardmäßig.
Ich bin enttäuscht.
Alles andere so gut.
Wie...
Oh.
Markdown Images.
Ich muss...
Markdown Inline Images.
Image.
Copy-paste mir das immer aus...
Ach.
Mit ähm...
Doppelpunkt.
What?
Ne.
Also man muss den Ausrufezeichen davor machen.
Genau.
Ah ja, ja.
Da ist es.
Ausrufezeichen waren es.
Genau.
Und man konnte das dann auch noch irgendwie zentrieren und Dings...
Da muss man sich mal das ähm...
Das Cheat-Cheat angucken von den...
Genau.
So mache ich meine Presentations.
Bloß, dass ich das meistens alles zusammen copy-paste.
Von der Syntax her.
Ja.
Aber so sieht das aus.
Und das einfach da als PDF exportieren.
Ich frag mich, wie das hier mit der Web-App funktioniert.
Wie...
Wie würde man die Web-App...
Wie würde man da jetzt was exportieren?
Ach hier.
Save.
Okay, man...
Es...
Es speichert als Markdown und man kann es dann als PDF speichern.
Aber...
Print?
Ach so.
So vielleicht.
Kommen dann...
Kommen dann mehrere Seiten da raus?
Documents?
Schauen wir mal.
Hallo?
Ja.
Haben wir es doch.
Gut, Chat.
Jetzt einfach Fullscreen.
Ja.
So, jetzt einfach Fullscreen.
Fertig.
Presentation.
Wobei die Zoom-Level-Fit automatic brauchen wir.
Und jetzt Fullscreen.
Presentation-Mode.
Was auch immer.
Scheiß drauf.
Ähm.
Tja.
So...
So mache ich Presentations.
Ja, Nico.
Kann jeder machen, was er will.
Ja.
Ab wenn PowerPoint lieber ist, da gibt es halt nicht viel, was du drin machen kannst.
Also ich muss sagen.
Ich finde.
Ich finde das, wie sie das in Elementary gemacht haben, finde ich wirklich schick.
Das gefällt mir.
Ich glaube, das ist das, was Einsteiger noch am wenigsten abschreckt.
Der Vorteil davon ist, ich finde das ist wichtig, es sieht auch gar nicht erst aus wie Windows.
Wenn man von der App die Präsentation starten könnte.
Naja, wie gesagt, bisher habe ich einfach immer PDF exportiert und dann PDF aufgemacht und Fullscreen, fertig.
Wenn man dann einen gescheiten PDF-Reader hat, der das einfach auch richtig skaliert, ist gut.
Was hältst du von Deepin?
Ich habe schon ewig nicht mehr probiert, das war das China-Linux, hat mir auch ganz gut gefallen von der Optik her.
Also, ich finde es aber echt schick hier, weil, also, wie lange installiert der eigentlich die Updates?
Oder ist der schon fertig?
Ich glaube, der installiert immer noch Updates.
Macht der da drei Stunden?
Drei Stunden für, oder was?
Wisst ihr, woran das liegt?
Ich weiß, woran das liegt, dass der drei Stunden Updates installiert.
Wo wir schon wieder dabei sind, wenn man eine Weile mit Linux arbeitet, du gehst einfach ganz instinktiv.
Kein Wim?
Fuck, warum ist da kein Wim drauf?
Du gehst einfach ganz instinktiv ins Terminal und machst einen Text-Editor auf.
Das muss weg.
DE-Archiv.
Das spackt immer rum.
Das ist lahm wie Sau.
So.
Let's cancel.
Jetzt gucken wir mal.
Jetzt geht es bestimmt viel schneller, klar.
Kein Wim.
Nein, VI ist drauf.
Wir gucken gleich nochmal, was sonst noch so dabei ist.
Das ist halt auch die Sache.
Sowas ist halt einfach über einen Terminal viel einfacher zu machen, als über ein grafisches GUI, ne?
Also, mir gefällt das.
Also, ich glaube, für Einsteiger ist Elementary wirklich ganz nett.
Das Schöne ist halt, es sieht noch nicht mal aus wie Windows und das ist wichtig, wenn du, wenn du, sobald du Linux aussehen lässt wie Windows, gehen die Leute auch direkt damit ran, dass sie denken, dass es wie Windows ist und kommen dann auf so Ideen, wie sich eine Exit downloaden und ausführen wollen und sowas.
Das sieht nicht aus wie Windows, das sieht eher aus wie Mac.
Was ist das hier?
Code.
Code-Raw.
Guck mal, die haben sogar den, die haben sogar diesen Settings-Button überall an der Karte.
An der gleichen Stelle.
Also, ich finde das wirklich gut, was die, was die hier gemacht haben.
Haben wir Hack installiert.
Hack ist der beste Font.
Ohne Hack geht nix.
Jetzt haben die standardmäßig für ein Font, ich weiß nicht, was das für ein Font ist, aber das geht auch halbwegs klar.
Man muss den Kram nur ein bisschen größer machen.
Include.
Blub.
Klopft.
Also, für Einsteiger ist das wirklich schick.
Also, mir gefällt das.
So, was haben wir hier standardmäßig dabei?
Es ist auch, es ist auch sehr übersichtlich.
Was dabei ist, ne?
Wir haben, wir haben ein Screenshot-Tool dabei.
Wir haben Maus-Pointer, bla bla bla.
Cancel.
Es geht auch wieder auf.
Hier, ausschneiden.
Take Screenshots.
Es ist ein ordentliches Screenshot-Tool dabei.
Das ist schon mal was.
Es ist ein Calculator dabei.
Easy.
Graphics.
Ist nur ein Bildbetrachter dabei.
Auch okay.
Internet.
Ist so ein, ist halt ein hässlicher Browser mit dabei, aber warum nicht?
E-Mail ist, was ist denn das für ein E-Mail-Programm?
Hat irgendjemand eine Ahnung, was das für ein E-Mail-Programm ist?
Kannst du das nicht ausprobieren, weil, weil, ne?
Wir geben, wir geben mal Fake, wir geben mal Fake ein.
At, at example.com.
So, wir faken jetzt einfach mal.
Oh, der lässt mich noch nicht mal weitermachen.
Das ist ja gemein.
Nicht nur für Einsteiger.
Wir verwenden das professionell.
Okay.
Äh, in welchem Bereich arbeitest du?
Nope.
Mail.
Das Mail-Programm heißt einfach Mail.
Unten drunter ist halt immer noch ein Ubuntu.
Das heißt, man kann auch alles installieren, was man will.
OKS-Farbe.
Yes.
Danach starten wir mal neu und gucken.
Viele Ahnung von Grund Neuprogrammiert.
Ja, ich finde, man sieht das auch.
Das, das, das wird, das ist kein Thunderbird oder kein, kein, ähm,
Contact oder kein Evolution.
Ich bin grad nicht draufgekommen, wie das Gnome-E-Mail-Programm heißt.
Und ab dem Moment, wo ich höre Ubuntu, bin ich schon leider wieder, warum?
Ubuntu ist doch ein super Unterbau.
Das einzige, was an Ubuntu suckt, ist, ist der Standard-Desktop.
Und wo Ubuntu auch nicht so schön ist, ist, wenn du halbwegs, also wenn du richtig.
Nicht nur moderne Pakete, sondern so.
Sag mal so schon, fast schon Bleeding Edge moderne Pakete brauchst.
Irgendwelche Pakete, die dann wieder crashen.
OK, was, was auch immer.
Also, ich sehe da kein Problem.
Alle meine Server laufen mit Ubuntu, da crasht nix.
Linux Mint, ja, Linux Mint ist, ist ja auch Ubuntu.
War es zumindest früher, aber ich denke mal, ist immer noch so.
Ja, Zugucker muss, das muss sich jeder selbst überlegen.
Kann man die Transparenz ausschalten?
Die Transparenz nervt mich.
Oh, Sonnenbrille.
Kann man?
OK, jetzt, jetzt geht's los.
Wie kann man die Transparenz im Terminal ausschalten?
Das ist wahrscheinlich total einfach, wenn man in Elementary-OS-Logik denkt.
Ähm, OK, gucken wir mal, was noch dabei ist.
Ein Kalender ist dabei, OK.
Ein Programming, so ein Texteditor ist dabei.
Kamera, Videoplayer, Musikplayer.
Support Z, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Nice.
Twitch Prime.
System Tools, App Center.
System Settings, da kann man das bestimmt irgendwo einstellen.
Das E-Mail-Programm heißt tatsächlich einfach nur Mail.
Warum nicht?
Ja, mit dem Zahnrad habe ich schon probiert.
Da kannst du die Transparenz nicht ausschalten.
OK, suchen wir mal.
Wie geht das?
Hallo?
Seite, du darfst laden.
Warum?
Browser, warum bist du so langsam?
Ach, ich glaube weil er im Hintergrund geupdatet wurde.
Turn off Transparency in Wing Panel G Settings.
Moment, was?
Die Font Settings sind komisch.
Ihhh.
Ok, wo kann man?
Da?
Ne.
Hä?
Was für ein Menü hat der Typ da auf?
Ach ne, Moment, das hat damit gar nichts zu tun.
Elementary Tweaks.
Was war das?
Das finde ich schon wieder.
Moment, was?
Also, ich habe hier, wie auch immer.
Ich habe hier die Elemental-Tricks.
Okay.
Und hier, ich habe hier die Elemental-Tricks.
Elementary Tweaks.
Was auch immer das ist.
Das fände ich jetzt schon mal wieder unnötig kompliziert.
Okay, es ist geupdatet.
Wir rebooten mal.
Wie kann man eigentlich am besten die Steuerung von einem
Arduino-Projekt machen? MQTT, ein normales
Programm schreiben oder eine Webseite?
Was meinst du mit Steuerung?
Meinst du jetzt,
wie du am besten eine Übersicht
machen kannst für mehrere
Controller?
Oder wie du den einzelnen Controller
am besten steuerst?
Sie haben sogar
ein Einfaden vom
Logo am Anfang.
Das erinnert mich schon zu sehr an Windows
10. Ach stimmt,
irgendjemand hat auch geschrieben, sie verwenden das professionell
und ich habe gefragt, in welchem Bereich
ihr arbeitet. Ich habe jetzt die Antwort gar nicht gesehen.
Ähm,
Web Development, ach da.
Ja, kann ich mir gut vorstellen,
dass es damit angenehm
ist, ja.
Ja, weißt du, wie man im Terminal die Transparenz abschaltet?
Wenn ihr das professionell verwendet,
ich meine, das
kann nicht so kompliziert sein.
Ich glaube, das hat
gar keine Transparenz. Das hat einfach
nur einen sehr hellen
Hintergrund.
Das gehört, glaube ich, einfach so.
Cybernudel,
Twitch Prime, danke schön.
Aber alles in allem, finde ich
schick. Wie
verschiebt man jetzt
das Terminal auf den
zweiten Desktop?
Ja, das ist schön, das gefällt mir.
Also, das ist wirklich, glaube ich, auch für Noobs
zum Einstieg schick, weil
es sieht gut aus, das ist ja schon mal wichtig.
Wenn du irgendwie, wenn du, wenn du
irgendwas installierst,
verwendest und es sieht
crappy aus, dann hast du schon keinen Bock.
Ähm,
es sieht vor allem auch überhaupt
nicht aus wie Windows.
Das ist auch schon mal gut.
Es hat ein sinnvolles,
eine sinnvolle Auswahl an Standardprogrammen,
und ist halt auch überhaupt nicht
überladen.
Man hat einen,
man hat einen grafischen Paketmanager,
der auch ganz brauchbar
aussieht, finde ich.
Was kann man da alles zum Beispiel nachinstallieren?
Snaptastic.
Drei Dollar. Na gut, kann ich mit
leben. Ach, hier oben
sind, ah, hier oben sind die Apps,
die für Elementary
angepasst wurden, und hier unten
sind die Standard-Ubuntu-Apps.
Was finde ich
eine sinnvolle Regelung,
dass das, da sieht man, welche Apps
quasi so funktionieren,
wie halt das
Elementary gedacht hat, und du kannst trotzdem
alles installieren, was
in Ubuntu drin ist, was du willst.
Äh, äh, äh, Niki,
das hängt davon ab, was du machen willst. Also,
wenn du es über die Kommandozeile
bedienen willst, dann Konsolenanwendungen,
wenn du mehrere Controller
über eine Webseite bedienen
willst, okay. Über eine Webseite ist es halt
nicht so einfach. Über eine Webseite brauchst du auf jeden Fall,
auf jeden Fall noch ein Backend, was dann deine
Befehle zum, zum Controller schickt.
Das, das kommt auf den Anwendungsfall
an. 170 Viewer, ja, nice.
Pock.
Kommt ihr denn alle her
auf einmal?
Weil auf der anderen Seite, das ist mittlerweile,
seitdem ich regelmäßig strebe,
muss ich ja sagen, ist es, ist
es recht, recht
regelmäßig 150 plus, ne?
Ach ja, äh, der Lai Boomster
hat natürlich recht. Du kannst,
mit deinem, wenn das ein
ESP32 ist, ich glaube auf dem ESP
2866 geht's auch, aber
beim ESP32 ist
ein Webserver dabei, mit der du relativ
simpel Webseiten ausliefern kannst
von deinem ESP32.
Aber so wie ich's
verstanden habe, willst du eher was Zentrales, wo du
mehrere Controller mitsteuern kannst.
Du willst ja eine zentrale Webseite haben, wo
du über MQTT mehrere Controller steuern kannst.
Am einfachsten, ganz ehrlich,
ich würde ein Shell-Skript basteln,
was meine MQTT-Befehle abschickt und das
ist dann, das ist die einfachste
Variante.
Ich weiß, QChat, gefällt das
Wort MQTT
unglaublich. Kannst du nur
mit Elementary Tweaks ausschalten?
Ja, das hab ich gelesen, aber wie installiert man
Elementary Tweaks?
Elementary Tweaks GitHub
2017, okay.
Wie installiert
man das? Ach hier,
einfach Repo hinzufügen.
Dazu fällt mir jetzt bloß noch ein.
Aber ein Raspberry Pi zentralen
Server. Also, ganz ehrlich,
ich würde mir erstmal ein Shell-Skript basteln,
Niki, was das macht, für mich.
Ähm, und danach
würde ich mir eine Webseite bauen, die ich auf dem
Raspberry laufen kann, laufen lassen
kann. Ich würde mir ein Shell-Skript erstmal
basteln, wo meine ganzen MQTT-Befehle
drin sind, die
What?
From Software Repositories
Common, okay.
Ah, jetzt.
Guck mal hier.
Sogar das Terminal kann sogar
Desktop-Notifications, wenn ein Hintergrund
Befehl
fertig ist.
Das ist ja richtig gut gemacht.
Huge.
Guck mal, es warnt dich sogar davor,
wenn du ein Sudo-Kommando copy-pastest.
Warum? Was hat er jetzt
für Probleme?
Äh, Kyokun, ja, das ist, ähm,
generell die Sounds,
Icons und alles das Design.
Ich finde auch den Default-Benachrichtigungs-Sound,
wie du gesagt hast, ist wirklich schick gemacht.
Da ist es doch.
Findest du von der Usability nicht gut?
Ich, okay, du hast es wahrscheinlich
schon länger ausprobiert, aber ich muss
sagen, ich tue mir mit allem schwer,
was nicht i3 ist, deswegen bin ich da kein Maßstab
für. Ähm,
aber von der Konsistenz her,
Konsistenz her, finde ich es echt schick.
Wie, wie, wie,
wie starten mir diese, diese Tweaks jetzt?
Wie, wie, wie startet
man das jetzt?
Tweak? Wie, wie,
wie startet man das jetzt?
Muss man die Settings dafür aufmachen?
Tweaks, da ist es.
Das hätte man vielleicht mal hinschreiben können,
weil ich meine, ich, ich, als ich das Bild
gesehen habe, dachte ich mir, vielleicht ist es in den
normalen Settings.
Elementary? Pass auf, jetzt wird es eklig.
Bäh.
Prefer Dark Variant.
Nope.
Ach, man kann
das umstrahlen, das ist cool.
Weil ich werde mich nie dran gewöhnen,
wenn man, wenn man Fenster auf der linken Seite
zumachen muss.
Ich vergesse, ich werde mich da nie dran gewöhnen.
Terminal, Background, ach hier.
Da kann man aber nicht die, nicht die, den, den
Font ändern.
Background Color.
Jetzt kann man es mal auf, auf komplett schwarz stellen,
das Terminal, ja.
Das ist mit dem Default Farbschema schon besser.
Paste Alert kann man ausschalten.
Äh, Niki fragt, wie kann ich das auswählen?
Wie gestaltet ihr Webseiten, wenn sie halbwegs schön werden sollen?
HTML, CSS und Go?
Und nutzt ihr ein Programm zum grafischen Gestalten?
Ne, ne, ne, ne. Kein Grafik, kein Tool.
Also kein Frontpage oder sowas.
Einfach einen Editor.
CSS, HTML.
Und, ähm,
ganz wichtig, installiert ihr den Auto-Reload-Plugin.
Und machst du nämlich
auf der linken Bildschirmhälfte,
machst du deinen Editor auf, auf der rechten Bildschirmhälfte,
machst du deinen Browser auf
und jedes Mal, wenn du speicherst,
refreshst du das automatisch.
Ich würde es mir erstmal ordentlich
designen mit CSS, HTML
und danach kannst du immer noch ein bisschen
JavaScript-Zeugs dabei basteln.
Kann man hier noch einstellen?
Lautstärke, Animations, Fonts.
Das ist ein ordentliches
der Android-Font.
Allerdings Dark, Dark-Theme scheint nicht zu funktionieren.
Vielleicht muss man
dafür aber auch neu starten.
Kann das sein, dass man dafür neu starten muss, vielleicht?
Neu starten für Dark-Theme?
Probieren wir mal aus.
Es hat sogar ein hübsches Reboot-Logo.
Genau,
VS Code Live Server, stimmt.
Haben wir sogar mal hier on stream verwendet.
Hab ich schon wieder ganz vergessen.
Da brauchst du kein, kein
zusätzliches Live-Reload-Geschiss mehr.
Und jetzt ist es
Dark? Jetzt ist es Dark.
Ja gut, außer der Browser.
Ist schick, ist schick.
Gefällt mir.
Sharing. Achso, sharing.
So für Twitter und Gedöns.
Hintergründe.
Das ist ja das Wichtigste für die meisten Leute,
erstmal einen gescheiten Hintergrund zu haben.
Ah, grün.
Wenigstens haben die mal ein paar
halbwegs schicke
Bilder zur Auswahl
im Hintergrund.
Hier für die Schweizer.
Ah.
Ja, den.
Tja, also
von beiden
von beiden Betriebssystemen, die
wir ausprobiert haben, muss ich ehrlich sagen,
da gefällt mir Elementary
doch deutlich besser
für Einsteiger. Es ist runder,
was die Default-Auswahl
angeht an Programmen, wie das
funktioniert. Und was
ich halt echt gut finde,
es ist hübsch, aber es sieht
überhaupt nicht aus wie Windows.
Nutzt ihr zum Proggen auch
XAMPP? Nö.
XAMPP ist
PHP, MySQL
und Apache. Das verwendet eigentlich
kaum noch einer in der Kombination.
Du verwendest
mittlerweile eigentlich
für
Web-Anwendungen, ich meine, du kannst PHP
verwenden, ja.
Für Web-Anwendungen
hast du eigentlich hauptsächlich
heute, also du hast viele Sachen in Node.
Du hast
die Oldschool Sachen sind in Ruby, aber
das verwendet man heute eigentlich gar nicht mehr. Viele machen
was in Go.
ASP.NET Core ist natürlich auch
angesagt.
Aber Node
ist schwer angesagt
für...
Ich persönlich bin ja ASP.NET Core Fan.
Ja, gut.
Dagegen
kann MX Linux einpacken.
Gefällt mir nicht so gut.
Wobei ich denke,
wenn man was für
schwache Laptops braucht,
vielleicht MX Linux gar nicht
so verkehrt. So, wie viel Speicherplatz haben wir jetzt
verbraucht davon? 20G.
Okay, doch.
Was hat denn das hier eigentlich
standardmäßig für...
Kann man hier Shortcuts drinnen ändern?
Ne.
Ah, doch. Das ist echt, das ist
wirklich durchdacht. Das gefällt mir gut.
Ich meine, ich würde es nicht
auf der Arbeit verwenden, weil es mir auf den Keks
geht, so viel mit der Maus machen zu müssen.
Aber das ist doch, das ist die erste
wirklich stimmige
Linux-Desktop-Distribution, die ich
gesehen habe. Gibt es für Node.js
Freehouse zum Rumspielen?
Gute Frage. Aber du brauchst
eigentlich gar keinen
Freehouse.
Du kannst dir mittlerweile so
günstig
Sachen mieten.
Wenn es schnell gehen soll,
gehst du zu DigitalOcean und
holst dir
eine VM.
Ja, Heroku ist auch
angesagt. Stimmt. Ja.
Das ist auch im Trend. Seit Jahren schon.
Und wenn sich eine Sache
jahrelang hält, dann...
kann die in dem Umfeld nicht schlecht sein.
Gibt es auch ein gutes
Einsteiger-Linux, was nicht
Desktop-basiert ist?
Naja, du kannst einfach einen Ubuntu installieren.
Du kannst den Ubuntu Server installieren.
Ubuntu Server
ist ein super Betriebssystem
für
0 nach 15 Kisten,
die einfach nur da stehen sollen und laufen.
Wenn du gar keinen Desktop willst,
ist das nicht verkehrt.
Also wenn du keinen Desktop willst, gehe ich halt mal davon aus,
du willst das auf irgendeinem Remote-System oder auf
irgendeinem Server laufen lassen.
Deswegen würde ich sagen, nimm Ubuntu Server.
Ich bin...
fahre da seit Jahren mit...
gut im privaten
Umfeld.
Im Business-Umfeld haben wir Red Hat.
Die meisten wahrscheinlich.
Aber wenn ich die Auswahl habe zwischen
Red Hat und Ubuntu Server, ich würde mich für Ubuntu Server
entscheiden.
Die machen zwar auch merkwürdige Dinge,
ja, zum Beispiel wie ihre...
Achso, ganz wichtig, wir müssen das
ASCII-Quarium installieren.
Was Ubuntu teilweise
merkwürdiges macht, sind so ihre
Netzwerk-Config über YAML.
Wer auch immer sich das ausgedacht
hat...
Und... wie, es gibt kein ASCII-Quarium?
Ich bin enttäuscht.
Wer auch immer sich ausgedacht
hat bei Canonical, dass das
eine gute Idee ist,
der hat
sie nicht mal...
Kann man das hier rüberschieben? Wow.
Hey.
YAML-Datei für Netzwerk-Config.
Ganz ehrlich, die haben auch den Schussnehmer gehört.
Was sagt ihr? Apache
oder Nginx? Nginx.
Auf jeden Fall Nginx.
So wie der Chat das sagt.
Ich geb dem Chat recht. Aber ist ja auch Q-Chat.
CentOS?
Nö. Wie gesagt, es ist ja Red Hat.
CentOS ist ja Red Hat.
Haben wir auf der Arbeit.
Damit kann man arbeiten.
Es ist nicht so, dass es schlimm wäre. Im Prinzip
ist so ein Riesenunterschied zwischen den ganzen
Linux-Systemen nicht. Das hängt so ein bisschen
von der Philosophie des jeweiligen
Anbieters noch ab. Aber ansonsten
ähm...
Zumindest für den privaten Umfeld finde ich
Ubuntu-Server viel angenehmer als CentOS.
Ich überleg grad, wie...
Woran das liegt.
Ich bin da voll von überzeugt.
Aber ich überleg grad, woran liegt das?
Warum gefällt mir Ubuntu-Server besser?
Ich glaub, das liegt einfach mit daran, weil
es... weil die Sachen
sich eher an Stellen
befinden, wo ich mit rechne,
dass sie sich befinden. Aber es ist
kein Riesenunterschied letztendlich.
Äh, hier Homeworld.
Das kann natürlich sein. Im Business-Umfeld
keine Ahnung. Also ich hab mit
Canonical noch nie Erfahrung gemacht, wenn's um
irgendwelche Support-Geschichten geht.
Und überhaupt.
Also das...
Sind die bei den Updates echt so langsam?
Na gut. Wenn du...
Wenn du natürlich mehrere
Public-Server hast, die von außen erreichbar sind,
wo dann auch... wo's auch wichtig ist,
und die Updates sind zu langsam, da ist das natürlich
ein Argument, ja.
Ja, Debian hab ich schon ewig nicht mehr installiert.
Also... Na doch, das stimmt nicht.
Ich glaub, Debian hab ich mit Abstand am meisten installiert,
weil alle Raspberries mit Debian laufen.
Ja, aber ansonsten...
Wie gesagt, meine ganzen Serverkisten
laufen privat
immer mit Ubuntu-Server, und auf der Arbeit
ist es halt Red Hat.
Beziehungsweise CentOS.
Einfach weil Business.
Ja, man muss sagen, Red Hat hat schon seine Vorteile.
Wenn man sich beispielsweise
die ganzen Security-Tracker
und sowas anguckt, und...
Du hast ja bei Red Hat auch tatsächlich Leute,
wenn du da was reportest, dann kümmert man sich drum,
wie das unter Ubuntu ist, weiß ich nicht.
Ich hab bei... im Ubuntu Bug-Tracker schon
Bugs gesehen, die sind vier Jahre alt,
wo es darum ging, dass ich, ähm...
quasi bei der falschen Netzwerk-Config
es ne Curdle-Panic gibt und so komische Dinger,
wo ich mir denke, ey, das ist auch schon seit vier Jahren
gefixt, warum ist das immer noch nicht da?
Bei der LTS-Version
wohl gemerkt, ja.
Also bei Ubuntu steht halt tatsächlich,
da muss ich Home-Welt schon recht geben,
ähm, bei Ubuntu nehmen sie es mit LTS
nicht so ganz ernst.
Zum Beispiel, als diese ganze, ähm...
Meltdown-Geschichte
rausgekommen ist,
die Ubuntu-Version, die da...
also quasi die
letzt-supportete Ubuntu-Version,
die noch supported
war, wo Meltdown rausgekommen ist,
da haben die einfach, ich mein, das Support-Ende war
in zwei Monaten oder so, haben die einfach
mal entschieden, nö.
Dafür gibt's keine Meltdown-Patches mehr.
Was total hirnrissig ist.
Wenn man sagt, man supportet eine Distribution
bis, keine Ahnung,
November
2019,
dann hat's, wenn das im Support-Zeitraum ist,
dann hat es gefälligst Sicherheit-Patches
dafür zu geben. Alles andere ist komplett
hirnrissig.
Weil wenn die mit so nem Mist anfangen, was sie ja gemacht
haben und sagen, ja nee, nur weil das Ding
nächsten Monat nicht mehr supported ist,
kriegt der wichtige Sicherheits-Features nicht,
dann stellt sich ja komplett in Frage, ob
die nicht einfach ihre Support-Zeiträume
quasi
bei dem kleinsten Problem schon umschmeißen.
Ja, das muss natürlich nicht sein.
Da hatte ich jetzt daheim nicht so das Problem.
Weil ob mein
Server hier, der da hinter mir steht,
Meltdown verwundbar
ist oder nicht,
oder Spectre oder sonst was,
da gibt's Schlimmeres, ja.
Wenn der mal nicht sofort Patches kriegt.
Aber,
dass sie das für supportete Versionen noch sagen,
dass es keine neuen Sicherheits-Patches gibt,
obwohl die Sachen noch supported sind,
das kann's eigentlich nicht sein.
Und das ist was, das wird mit Red Hat echt nicht passieren.
Red Hat nimmt, und sogar Microsoft,
ja, sogar Microsoft, die nehmen
ihre Support
Versprechen ziemlich ernst.
Wenn
Red Hat sagt, der Kram ist
bis da und dann supported,
da kannst du von ausgehen,
der ist bis dahin supported,
eher noch ein paar Tage länger,
und sogar bei Microsoft ist es so,
wenn da was quasi
nicht mehr in ihrem,
wenn da irgendwas end of life ist,
die Patchen, es gibt teilweise
Jahre nach dem Support-Ende von XP
kommen da noch
ganz vereinzelt Sachen mit.
Wo XP auch noch
dabei steht.
Also da haben sie sich bei Canonical Ubuntu
echt nicht mit rumbekleckert.
Achso, äh,
ja, das...
Ja, äh,
Tensor, hier, ähm,
das ist ja grad nur das,
was wir ausprobieren, Linux-technisch.
Das eigentliche Linux, was ich verwende, ist hier,
ähm,
Evaluation Expired.
Ne, das eigentliche Linux, was ich verwende, ist hier
Manjaro mit i3.
Das sieht dann so aus.
Und das ist,
für mich, ey, das ist der Wahnsinn, ne?
Für den normalen Benutzer, der wird wahrscheinlich
sagen, oh, das hier ist richtig
heiß und, und so
gefällt mir das, so stell ich mir das vor
und alles toll.
Für den normalen Benutzer ist diese Oberfläche hier viel
viel cooler irgendwie, denk ich mal, und viel
bedienbarer. Aber ich krieg kein Anfälle
dafür, wenn ich so viel mit der Maus machen muss.
Für mich ist es so, wenn ich auf meinen i3-Desktop
umschalte, ist es für mich
Erholung pur, ey. Es geht alles
mit Tastatur zu bedienen, äh,
das ist mein Staubsauger-Roboter,
den will ich jetzt nicht anschalten.
Es geht alles per Tastatur, es ist alles
schnell, es, es switcht ins
Instant, und das Wichtigste ist,
ich hab, ich hab Askiquarium drauf,
ohne das geht ja eh schon mal gar nichts, äh.
Oh, da wird er geangelt.
Hast du mal Arch
an T-Cross benutzt? Nö.
IP liegt.
Mock heißt
Windows 10 ist okay. Windows 10 hat
aber, muss man sagen, Windows 10
hat irgendwie immer
mal wieder so Macken, wo ich nicht weiß, wo
das Ganze herkommt. Zum Beispiel
heute Morgen
hatte meine, hatte
die, hatten die Icons auf meinem Desktop,
die Schrift von den Icons auf
meinem Desktop, hatte kein,
kein, äh, Outline.
Das war komplett weiß, das hast du überhaupt
nicht mehr gesehen.
Reboot, ging wieder.
Das ist halt
Windows-Logik.
DDoS startet, auf Leute, gibt's, gibt alles.
Localhost, go, go.
Gleich bist du weg, haha.
Localhost.
Was geht mit meinem Desktop?
So, was soll mit meinem Desktop gehen?
So, Leute, ähm,
was haben wir denn hier noch für offene Fragen?
Was hat Red Hat für
Vorteil? Einen ewig langen
Support-Zeitraum und wenn man, äh,
wenn man für Support bezahlt, auch Leute,
die sich um die Probleme kümmern.
Stimmt. Hätten wir auch machen können.
Ah, top.
Was hältst du eigentlich von Deep, ah, das habe ich schon
beantwortet vorhin.
Wie machst du eigentlich das Resize mit der Windows-Taste?
Ähm, Windows-Taste,
gedrückt halten und mit der rechten
Maustaste das Fenster bewegen, dann
Resize da.
Äh, Niki, kannst du auch machen, ja.
Ich glaube, es gibt keine.
Als nächstes Kali-Linux. Ich glaube, da gibt's
nicht so vieles zu sehen.
Also Desktop-mäßig, das ist ja, das ist ja
eine Distribution für Security-Zwecke.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen
i3 und i3-VM? Das ist das gleiche.
Genau, und
ich persönlich bin ja Fan von Pop!OS,
ja. Ich habe sie mir schon aufgeschrieben
das nächste Mal. Was wäre an Distributionen
noch pro Hanna-Montana-Linux?
Oh Gott.
Das könnten wir echt mal machen.
Ähm,
Mint und Pop!OS
Manjaro habe ich mir schon aufgeschrieben.
Ja, und ich bin auch Fan
von i3 mit Gaps.
Gaps sind eigentlich der unnützeste
Scheiß überhaupt, aber ich finde es
schöner, weil die Fenster sich ein bisschen besser
voneinander abgrenzen.
Das hier sind Gaps, also dass du ein bisschen
Abstand zwischen den einzelnen Programmen hast, die du startest.
Ich finde es schick mit Gaps.
Manche
Leute sagen, Gaps wären sinnlos.
Das sind halt die Gaps.
Ich finde es aber gut, weil
das grenzt irgendwie die Fenster schöner voneinander ab.
Gentoo und Linux vom Scratch, jetzt übertreibt
man nicht.
Gentoo ja, Linux vom Scratch bestimmt nicht.
Von MX Linux, ja das haben wir heute ausprobiert.
Das fand ich jetzt nicht so dolle.
Schon jemand Hurt ausprobiert.
Ne, wie heißt man das? Hurt?
Nein.
Und habe ich auch nicht vor, weil es
nichts ist, was man können muss
im Endeffekt, oder können will, oder
was mich auch nicht
interessiert, weil wozu?
Das ist eher sowas, wenn man mal
experimentelle Sachen ausprobieren will.
Weiß gar nicht, ob das überhaupt
auf dem richtigen Rechner aktuell noch bootet.
Ich glaube, das ist so ein reines, mittlerweile so ein
reines vm-only Ding.
Gibt es eine minimale Linux-Distribution
nur mit Basispaketen und nur Shell?
Wie gesagt, wenn du es benutzen willst
für einen Desktop oder für eine VM,
würde ich dir die Manjaro
Manjaro Minimal
Installation empfehlen.
Da ist im Endeffekt nichts
großartiges dabei.
Wenn du was für Container suchst,
dann kannst du Alpin
Linux nehmen.
ReactOS
ist doch Windows, oder?
Ist ReactOS
das
Windows-Ding?
Ich glaube schon, ja.
ReactOS. Das können wir auch mal ausprobieren
in einem der nächsten Streams.
Das ist dieses Fake Windows.
Das hier.
Ja.
Dieses Fake Windows
ist das ReactOS.
Gibt es Manjaro Minimal?
Ich habe jetzt nur den Architekt
gesehen. Nimm den Netinstall.
Da ist kein
Server dabei.
Nimm den Netinstall.
Warte mal, ich zeige es dir mal.
Ich habe schon ewig keins mehr installiert.
Die laufen halt einfach.
Hat Manjaro Upt oder Yum?
Pacman heißt das bei Manjaro.
Pacman.
Guck.
Oder der Joghurt, wobei
viele auf andere
Sachen schwören.
Oder der Joghurt für User-Pakete.
Ich weiß, Joghurt benutzen.
Ach so, genau.
Was für Manjaro du downloaden musst.
Wie das jetzt heißt.
Die Seite ist
Highspeed gerade.
Wow, die haben ja mittlerweile
voll die krass animierte Seite.
Hei, hei, hei.
Ist das die Architekt-Version?
Kann sogar sein.
Wahrscheinlich
ist es die Architekt-Version.
Ich bilde mir ein, das hieß Netinstall
früher.
Die offizielle E3
ist offizielle E3, würde ich nicht nehmen.
Ich würde es selber machen.
Okay, es gibt kein Netinstall mehr.
Dann würde ich die Architekt-Version nehmen.
You can also install base system without graphical user interface.
Ja, das willst du doch.
Das ist doch das.
Das können wir mal machen.
Ich habe schon so lange kein Manjaro mehr installiert.
Wir haben zwar mal einen Stream gemacht,
wo wir das eingerichtet haben,
aber das ist schon so lange her,
dass es wahrscheinlich überhaupt nicht mehr anwendbar.
Für einen Browser. Firefox ist standardmäßig.
Fuzzy Search.
Chrome nicht.
Und für Chrome fällt mir auch nichts Vergleichbares ein.
Okay, Netinstall gibt es nicht mehr.
Dann würde ich die Architekt-Version nehmen.
Gibt es eine Möglichkeit,
dass, wenn ich beim Quelltext
etwas aktualisiere, sich Nginx
automatisch neu startet?
Wozu musst du Nginx neu starten,
wenn du deinen Quelltext änderst?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Meinst du jetzt PHP, oder was?
Mit PHP?
Also normalerweise surft
der Nginx
standardmäßig erstmal deine statische
Webseite, also dein HTML
und dein CSS und dein
JavaScript. Dazu musst du auf
Nginx nichts aktualisieren, wenn du das änderst.
Du musst einfach deinen Browser refreshen.
Einfach den Browser refreshen.
Und wenn du PHP etwas entwickelst,
falls es wirklich PHP ist, würde ich
den eingebauten
Development-Server von PHP nehmen, solange ich
entwickle. Und nicht direkt Nginx.
Nginx würde ich dann eine fertige Anwendung
drin laufen lassen.
Aber für reines HTML,
CSS und JavaScript
brauchst du kein Nginx reloaden.
Bester Markdown-Editor?
Ja, da bin ich immer noch auf der Suche.
Ich verwende
ehrlich gesagt mittlerweile
Visual Studio Code.
Beziehungsweise
habe
früher immer
direkt den Wim geschrieben.
Und habe es dann ab und zu mal
rendern lassen und habe es mir angezeigt.
Es gibt auch einen Markdown-Live-Reload
für den Wim gibt es auch.
Aber Visual Studio Code ist
echt okay dafür.
Es wird halt
schnarchlangsam bei langen Markdown-Dokumenten.
Also wenn du
wirklich lange Markdown-Dokumente hast,
dann wird Visual Studio Code relativ
langsam was halt durch die Vorschau.
Dem Text-Editor macht das
nichts, aber die Vorschau ist halt lahm.
Das ist aber ein Ding, das liegt in der Natur
von Markdown.
Ich glaube, ich kenne zumindest
keinen
Markdown-Renderer
beziehungsweise Markdown-Editor mit eingebautem
Preview, der das inkrementell
machen kann. Also sprich, wenn du
in Markdown was änderst, wird jedes Mal
die komplette Seite neu gerendert.
Das heißt, wenn du eine ganz schön
lange Seite hast, so irgendwas mit
keine Ahnung 20.000 Zeilen oder so
und du änderst da was dran, dann ist es
lahm. Ja, QoNotes
hat das gleiche Problem. Das verwende ich übrigens.
QoNotes als Notizprogramm.
Das hat
einen ordentlichen Markdown-Editor, ja.
Und hat alles plaintext Markdown.
Allerdings
verwende ich die Vorschau davon nicht. Ich weiß gar nicht,
ob das eine Vorschau hat.
Ganz ehrlich, ich war
am Anfang auch der Meinung,
wenn man Markdown verwendet, braucht man
braucht man, Moment,
ich mach's hier mal auf.
Braucht man eine Live-Vorschau.
Allerdings, mittlerweile
denke ich nicht, dass man
überhaupt noch eine Vorschau braucht,
weil...
Ähm, mal weg da unten.
Terminal, geh mal zu.
Nee, Moment, wie mach ich denn schon?
Einfach zuklicken, ne?
Blub.md
Weil, ich verwende
mittlerweile das Syntax-Highlighting
vom Editor
so als Struktur
fürs Dokument.
Also, ich verwende das eigentlich nur noch,
um für mich Sachen irgendwie
bisschen schöner kenntlich zu machen.
Und, ähm, wenn ich's dann
irgendwann mal wirklich als
Webseite veröffentlichen muss
oder als Dokument oder so,
dann kann ich's immer noch rendern.
Also, ich verwende eigentlich bloß noch diese
Markdown-Syntax, dass halt
Überschriften fett gemacht werden und hervorgehoben
werden. Dass Listen halt ein bisschen
syntaktisch, äh,
stylenmäßig hervorgehoben werden.
Ich verwende keine Vorschau mehr.
Weil, letztendlich ist es unter der
Haube E-Plaintext.
Was hältst du von Windows 10
LTSC
auf einem Produktiv-PC?
Ist das diese Long-
Long-Term-Branch-Geschichte?
Wenn das diese Long-
Long-Term-Branch-Geschichte ist, haben wir das auf der Arbeit
auch, nur dass es da noch, noch, ähm,
noch
konservativer
eingeschaltet ist.
Die Dinger sind so alt,
da ist noch nicht mal
WSL dabei,
und es wurde noch nicht mal
der Edge aktiviert.
Wir kriegen, wir kriegen wahrscheinlich auf der Arbeit auf den
Windows-Kisten, glücklicherweise muss ich keine Windows-Kiste auf der Arbeit
verwenden. Wollen wir noch ein paar
Job-Anzeigen gucken, wo ich gerade dabei bin?
Wollen wir noch ein paar Job-Anzeigen gucken? Haben wir schon eine Weile
nicht mehr gemacht. Komm, wir gucken noch
vorm Schlafengehen, gucken wir noch ein paar Job-Anzeigen.
Ähm,
und das Witzige
ist,
dass wir wahrscheinlich Edge freigeschaltet
kriegen auf den Windows-Kisten, wenn Edge
schon gar nicht mehr Edge ist, sondern, sondern Chrome.
Aber zum Glück habe ich, ich habe ja meine
Linux-Kiste.
Zwei Linux-Kisten.
Irgendwie ist das ganz merkwürdig, ne?
So haben wir uns mal auf der Arbeit erzählt, so nach dem Motto,
ah, wir haben jetzt hier eine, eine neue
End-User-Strategie,
jeder kriegt nur noch ein,
nur noch ein Notebook,
und, ähm,
am besten Windows drauf
und so.
Und ich habe mir damals schon gedacht,
warten wir einfach mal ab, was
passiert, wenn du dich nicht rührst,
und auf einmal
steht da ein Kerl neben mir
und bringt mir ein neues Notebook vorbei,
und will mein altes Notebook
mitnehmen. Und ich sagte, ja, und?
Was ist mit meinem Zeug? Also,
wir können das jetzt nicht einfach
austauschen, da kann ich nicht mehr arbeiten.
Aber dann hat er gesagt, ja, auf dem neuen System ist
Windows drauf, wenn ich mich anmelde, melde ich mich
direkt mit meinem Standard-Account an. Da habe ich gesagt, nee, nee, Moment,
ich habe kein Windows auf meinem Notebook,
ich habe Linux auf meinem Notebook.
Ich brauche doch
Linux auf meinem Notebook, sonst kann ich nicht arbeiten gescheit.
Ähm, er sagt, ach so,
ja, hm, ja dann lasse ich ihnen
das neue Notebook einfach da.
Okay, seitdem habe ich zwei Notebooks.
Hat sich nie wieder einer dafür interessiert.
Letztens hat, letztens hat
die Hotline
angerufen, die sich auch
um, um, um, bei uns
um Aktualisierungen
für kleinen PCs kümmert,
also quasi, das ist Support,
und hat mich gefragt,
so was mit meinem windows ist das hätte schon lange keine security updates mehr
bekommen sagt ja das liegt daran weil er kein windows mehr drauf ist
deswegen hat es lange keine security updates mehr bekommen und er hat auch
nur so gesagt ach so ja ja dann ist okay alles in ordnung
sie ist jetzt immer noch mit zwei notebooks da jetzt vollkommen in ordnung
und ich werde jetzt so machen ich werde jetzt auf das eine auf das eine mit
tatsächlich wieder windows installieren lassen
dann habe ich nämlich den offiziellen windows von der firma und wenn irgendjemand
mal der meinung ist ich muss mal in einen konferenzraum mit so einem
surface habe was nur mit windows richtig funktioniert dann kann ich das mitnehmen
und zum täglichen arbeiten und ordentlich arbeiten und auch komfortabel
arbeiten und in der umgebung arbeiten
die ich gewöhnt bin und damit arbeiten kann aber ich weiter mein linux du musst
deinen chatlogger dark mode machen oh ja kann ich machen
wir haben noch leider keinen wir haben noch leider kein button für dark mode
sitzen die bei euch auch in indien der support nee wir haben eine eigene
hotline für support also ist das ist hotline und support in einem also client
client support die sitzen schon bei uns bist du auch für so bahnbar hier moment
was bist du auch für so bahnbar
bahnbarrieren wie in japan jetzt nach dem zugschubser die leute sollen sich
ordentlich benehmen am bahnhof es war die letzten 30 jahre auch kein problem und
die haben in die haben in frankfurt die letzten jahre übertrieben aufgerüstet
was bahn security und und und polizeipräsenz angeht das sind frankfurt
extrem gestiegen die letzten jahre und trotzdem gibt es immer mehr assis die
unterwegs sind ich nehme das wort gesocks nicht gerne
ins in den mund ja aber wenn man frankfurt um den hauptbahnhof herum
gelaufen ist
der wird mir da wahrscheinlich zustimmen
filezilla oder was anderes wenn fdp brauchst kannst du filezilla schon nehmen
aber ich glaube ich habe seit jahren kein fdp kleid angeschmissen würdest du dir
einen job suchen wenn du windows verändern müsstest kommt kommt also das
ist so eine typische frage wo man aus bauchgefühl mäßig sofort darauf sagen
wird nein aber natürlich hängt davon ab was das für ein job ist
krampf an was das für ein job ist wenn es an sich über das geile sache ist
es fette kohle gibt und sie sagenlla nur windows dann könnte ich mir auch
vorstellen nur windows zu verwenden allerdings würde ich dann gucken dass ich
vielleicht nicht doch irgendwie die möglichkeit hat das was ordentlich zu
installieren allerdings die jobs die richtig richtig geil sind die werden
wahrscheinlich gar nicht mal zwingend windows zu verwenden ich weiß es ist das
um nova estan seism Entwickler finde ich ingenausladen geht auch Estate iterations
fällt prinzipiell recht beliebt, zu sagen, ja,
wir wollen Windows haben für alle,
aber ich denke, wenn man
sich quasi Fachleute holt,
die sich um Linux-basierte
wie sagt man so schön,
nicht Infrastruktur,
Linux-basierte
Virtualisierungsumgebungen
und Linux-basierte
skalierbar, das ist das Wort, was ich gesagt habe,
skalierbare Containerumgebungen, was auch
immer noch alles kümmern, das ist ja zur Zeit
schwer angesagt, also sprich, wenn du da
wirklich Experten im
Linux-Bereich suchst,
denen dann für die tägliche Arbeit
Windows-Vornatz zu klatschen, weil man
ihnen nicht zutraut,
ihren eigenen Rechner ordentlich zu verwenden,
ist schon eben merkwürdig.
Ja, Kubernetes, was sonst, ist ja
das Ding schlechthin zur Zeit.
Kubernetes
K8s
Wobei ich sagen muss,
ich mach nicht so viel damit,
da.
Wow.
Ein Party-Parody kann ich doch nicht löschen.
Windows Explorer kann auch
FTP, ernsthaft.
Ja, Clocks HD, das ist
der Fake,
der fake, der indische fake Microsoft
indische Microsoft
Fake Support, ja.
Hello, this is Microsoft Support.
My name is Peter.
Aber ich komme aus
Indien und heiße zufälligerweise
Peter.
30 WoW Classic, ja allerdings nicht für den Stream.
Ich werde das ein bisschen
spielen, allerdings nur,
wenn entweder der Eax oder der Friseur
oder irgendjemand mitspielt.
Allerdings glaube ich nicht, dass ich das
ultra-hardcore-criten werde,
weil ich meine, das ist War Classic.
Achso, die Fortnite-Weltmeisterschaft erfolgt.
Nur ganz am Rande,
ich habe mitgekriegt, dass ein 16-Jähriger
Deutscher gewonnen hat, oder?
In den
Finale gewonnen hat,
in One-on-One, also
wie heißt das, Single-Q
oder Österreicher, ja.
Ich habe ein kleines
PC-Upgrade bestellt.
Kannst du mir deine Meinung dazu sagen?
Ja, dann kannst du posten, von was zu was du abgegradet hast.
Wie kann ich sonst den Quelltext,
den ich am PC schreibe, zu meinem Raspberry Pi
rüberbekommen ohne FTP?
Äh, SCP? Einfach SCP machen.
Das ist unter Linux das einfachste von der Welt,
Sachen zu kopieren. Du sagst einfach SCP,
äh,
dein Username,
nicki at raspberrypi
IP
äh,
ähm, achso, was ist denn hier?
File, so.
So, und hier schreibst du hin, wie das File dort heißen soll.
Oder machst einfach so.
Und dann kopierst du die Datei File
als User nicki auf dein Raspberry Pi, auf die IP
oder auf den Namen, wenn du DNS hast.
So, allerdings,
ich würde es gar nicht kopieren.
Ich würde es gar nicht kopieren.
Ich würde mich per SSH auf dem Raspberry einloggen,
und dort auf dem Raspberry dein Source Code editieren.
Das ist die einfachste Variante, die du machen kannst.
Wenn du es direkt auf dem Raspberry laufen lassen willst.
Äh, Homewell, weißt du, was das Witzige ist?
Es gibt ein Programm,
so ein Cisco-Netzwerk-Zeugs ist das,
das heißt wirklich Rangit.
Das ist der really awesome new Cisco,
nee,
really awesome new Cisco-Config-Differ.
Ist kein Scherz,
das Ding heißt wirklich so.
Rancid heißt es.
Rangit, ähm,
steht für
really awesome
new Cisco-Config-Differ.
Sag ich doch.
So einen Kack merkt man sich also.
Okay, gucken wir uns mal das PC-Upgrade an.
Von Aero...
Aerox.
So, von was hast du denn geupgradet?
Ist nur was Kleines, aber besser als mein jetziges.
Das sind...
Das jetzige ist sieben Jahre alt.
Okay, das ist auf jeden Fall besser.
Und kenne den genauen Prozessor noch nicht.
Ich habe noch DDR3 und sowas.
Okay, also, was hast du denn?
Äh, würde ich nicht mehr kaufen.
Weil, es gibt jetzt schon...
die neuen
Ryzen-Dinger.
Das ist kein neuer Ryzen, oder Leute?
Ich blicke bei der AMD-Bezeichnung immer noch nicht ganz durch.
Das ist noch ein Ryzen 2, oder?
Oder? Oder? Oder? Oder? Oder? Oder?
QChat sagt mir das meiste, so ein Ryzen 2.
Also, ich würde mir wahrscheinlich ein Ryzen 3 holen,
wenn ich mir jetzt einen neuen Rechner hole.
Na gut, und das, was das Mainboard hat,
und was, ähm...
wie viel RAM du brauchst, musst du im Prinzip selber wissen.
Also, AMD-Sachen profitieren ungemein von schnellem RAM,
habe ich gelesen.
Könnte man sich...
Müsste man mal gucken, wie viel das bringt,
wenn man sich ein bisschen schnelleren RAM holt.
Wie das preislich sich entwickelt.
Ähm...
Zu dem Mainboard kann ich nicht viel sagen.
Außer, dass die Mainboards mittlerweile ziemlich teuer sind.
100 Euro ist ja eines der günstigeren Mainboards noch.
Und das ist für Mainboards eigentlich schon teuer.
Du kannst 60 Euro für ein Mainboard bezahlen.
Das ist natürlich kein super High-End-Gaming,
sonst was Mainboard.
Jetzt hast du ein 3x PC.
Express.
Was hast du denn noch?
Einmal USB-C.
Im Jahr 2019, okay.
Aber dafür hat es 3x...
Ja, also...
Ich denke mal, allzu viel verkehrt machen kann man nicht.
Ähm...
Ich würde mich aber vorher mal schlau machen.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Ich bin da leider nicht so sehr auf dem aktuellen Stand.
Mein Bauchgefühl sagt mir,
dass ich wahrscheinlich einen Ryzen 3 nehmen würde,
wenn ich jetzt...
Was kaufe...
Ich würde mir auf jeden Fall kein RGB-RAM kaufen.
Ich würde mir kein RGB-RAM kaufen.
Auf keinen Fall.
Das ist viel zu teuer.
Nimm lieber was schnelleres.
An RAM.
Und dafür kein RGB.
Es sei denn, dir ist es wichtig,
dass es RGB hat.
Aber wenn man Low-Budget-Sachen machen will,
würde ich nicht unbedingt auf RGB-Beleuchtung gucken.
Guck mal, da hast du schon mal 20€ gespart.
Und der RAM ist schneller.
Ja.
Ach, ich guck ja auch nach 3200.
Ja, da kannst du mal 30€ sparen,
wenn du was ohne RGB nimmst.
Ja, und zu dem Mainboard kann ich nicht viel sagen.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass man damit viel mit falsch machen kann.
Wobei, mein Bauchgefühl sagt mir,
ich würde mir jetzt kein...
Kein Ryzen 2 mehr holen.
Hat nicht irgendwie Hardware-Rat
oder irgendjemand einen ordentlichen
Bauvorschlag?
Zen 2.
Wie viel kostet der CPU?
127.
Was kriegen wir denn da aktuell für?
Gar nichts.
Na gut, dann kann man sich's überlegen.
Dann müsste man mal schauen,
wie viel...
Wie viel schneller
der Ryzen 3 ist,
gegenüber dem Ryzen 2.
Ok, dann verstehe ich jetzt,
warum es ein Ryzen 2 ist.
Einfach, weil die nochmal 50, 50 bis 60€
billiger sind.
80€ billiger sind.
Das verstehe ich.
Das leuchtet ein.
Also, zu CPU und
Mainboard kann ich nicht so viel sagen.
Das einzige, was ich nicht machen würde,
ich würde keinen RGB-RAM kaufen.
RGB-RAM ist verschwendete Kohle,
die kannst du besser investieren.
Vielleicht kannst du auch beim Mainboard
noch ein bisschen was sparen.
Ich meine, du holst ja schon einen Ryzen 2,
das heißt, du kannst auch ohne Probleme
ältere Boards nehmen.
Was man übrigens mit den neuen Ryzen auch kann.
Da müssen wir mal genau gucken.
Ich würde vielleicht noch mal ein paar Tage drüber schlafen
und noch ein bisschen gucken,
was es für Möglichkeiten noch gibt.
Ich würde auf die ersten Ryzen Boards
auch Ryzen 3 drauf stecken.
Ich muss mal kurz Licht anmachen,
das ist schon übelst düster.
Aber wir wollten ja Stellenanzeigen gucken.
Gucken wir mal den.
Da sind, da sind,
muss ich gucken, dass ich jetzt nicht was
von dem Laden aufmache, wo ich arbeite oder so.
Das ist so das,
das Ding, wo viele Firmen massig Kohle bezahlen,
dass sie hier inserieren dürfen.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was an dieser Seite so super geil ist,
aber zumindest geben da viele Firmen
viel Kohle für aus.
Und die schlechtesten Jobsanzeigen
wie gesagt, gibt es auf Golemjobs.
Da sind, da sind
die größten Facepalm-Dinger drin.
Aber hast du mal den Trailer
zum neuen Windows-Terminal gesehen? Ja.
Wir haben uns sogar das neue Windows-Terminal schon im Stream
angeguckt.
Das ist auch schon mal toll. Anhand des Titels
habe ich keine Ahnung, um was es überhaupt
geht. Aber das liegt an mir.
Aber das liegt an mir.
Aber was zum Teufel
ist PMT
ADAS?
Okay, nach was für einer Stellenbeschreibung?
Suchen wir mal.
Komm, wir machen das mal
ganz billig. Wir suchen mal nach
Admin. Da gibt es doch bestimmt
jede Menge.
Administration. Da gibt es doch bestimmt
jede Menge. Nach DevOps
haben wir schon gesucht in Massen.
Aber jetzt gucken wir mal.
Da gibt es massig
Dinger für.
Oder was? Sysadmin. Das ist so
die ganz klassischere Variante.
Systems Engineer.
IT-Systemadministrator.
So reine
Admin-Sachen hätte ich echt keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Auch wenn ich das mal gelernt
habe vor Ewigkeiten.
Aber da hätte ich echt keinen Bock mehr
drauf.
Weil du bist ja oftmals auch der Depp vom Dienst.
IT-Support-Spezialist.
IT-Support-Spezialist. Das ist Hotline.
Das ist Hotline.
Unser Angebot als innovatives und wachsendes
Okay, das ist wieder bla bla bla bla.
Warum genau sollte
man da hingehen jetzt?
Aber das ist nett.
Komm, ich such mal wieder her.
Ich such mal was, wo ich dann auch was.
Wir haben einen DevOps
Senior DevOps.
Wie gesagt, ich mache schon DevOps
seit es nicht mal DevOps hieß.
Also wenn einer
Senior DevOps ist seit 10 Jahren,
dann noch der Max.
Möchtest du jetzt Hotline-Mitarbeiter
runterziehen?
Ne, ich will es bloß selbst nicht machen müssen.
Ich habe da überhaupt keine Geduld mehr für.
Dingsbums. Ja, das kann durchaus sein.
Also, wen haben wir hier?
ADSOS-Server. Das habe ich nie gehört.
Die suchen einen Senior Systems Engineer
für den Bereich Linux DevOps
in Frankfurt. Das ist auch schon mal schön.
Sales & Business Development.
Oh, da muss man bestimmt Anzüge anziehen.
Wir können auch mal
nach Cloud.
Was gibt es denn mit Cloud?
Cloud Engineer.
Cloud Architect.
Wir bleiben jetzt erst mal bei DevOps.
Okay, also.
Bla bla bla bla.
Es ist schon geil, ne?
Also, ernsthaft.
Wenn ein Drittel der Stellenanzeige
erstmal aus Selbstbeweihräucherung
besteht.
Okay, also wahrscheinlich ist das ziemlich uninteressant.
Die Unternehmen
gehören zu Einsteiger und Professionals
und Top-Adressen in der IT-Welt.
Bla bla bla bla.
Bla bla bla bla. Okay.
Also, was suchen sie? Ihre Aufgaben.
Ausbau, Weiterentwicklung und
Also, in der Regel kann man bei solchen Anzeigen
das ja erstmal schon mal komplett skippen.
Oder wurdest du gefeuert?
Nein.
Ich gucke eigentlich just for fun.
Da an die Null, da arbeite ich.
Echt?
Ob das ernst ist? Kann ja sein.
Also, nochmal dazu zu sagen.
Ich suche nicht wirklich einen neuen Job.
Aber
seit diesem Jahr
habe ich die Möglichkeit
einen neuen Job zu suchen.
Davor wäre es blöd gewesen, weil ich habe
die, wir hatten so ein Programm
zur betrieblichen Altersvorsorge, habe ich abgeschlossen.
Da musstest du eine gewisse Zeit dabei
bleiben. Und die Zeit ist jetzt rum.
Also, das heißt, jetzt könnte ich wieder was.
Und wenn es was Gutes gibt,
denke ich da auch drüber nach. Aber es ist nicht so,
dass ich jetzt unbedingt was suchen müsste.
Eigentlich gucke ich eher so ein bisschen just for fun.
Alle Optionen offen halten, genau.
Also, falls irgendjemand aus
Frankfurt zuguckt,
der in der Firma arbeitet,
oder der vielleicht selbst irgendwie
für den Bereich verantwortlich ist,
kann ja sein, man weiß ja nie, wer alles zuguckt.
Und ich suche noch Leute, wie gesagt,
entweder im
Administrationsbereich ungern,
im Cloud-Umfeld,
im Softwareentwicklungsumfeld,
im, natürlich am liebsten das, was ich schon
seit 15 Jahren mache,
im DevOps-Bereich. Und ich suche Leute,
dort vor allem für
Linux-Geschichten,
da bin ich für zu haben.
Je nachdem, um was es geht.
Ähm,
ja.
Und falls sich jetzt wirklich irgendjemand angesprochen hat,
der drüber nachdenkt, und sich denkt,
ah, der Max, der könnte doch da, das wäre doch nicht verkehrt,
dann schreibt mir einfach eine E-Mail
an meine
Business-E-Mail-Adresse.
Die findet ihr auf meinem Channel
hier. Ein bisschen Selbstjahre machen.
Die findet ihr auf meinem Channel hier, wenn ihr
auf YouTube geht.
Und dort auf Kanal-Info.
Da steht die Business-E-Mail-Adresse
drin. Das heißt, wenn es
irgendwas Interessantes gibt,
bin ich da auf jeden Fall
äh, gerade interessiert.
Oder können wir gucken.
Ich war ja schon überrascht letztes Jahr, ne?
Ich hab's bis Ende letzten Jahres, hab ich das ja auch
gesagt.
Ähm, Flo96,
naja, im Endeffekt ist es so. Warum
soll ich kündigen? Mein Job geht mir weder
sonderlich auf den Keks, noch finde ich's
irgendwie
so schlimm, dass man's nicht aushält oder so.
Warum soll ich kündigen? Ich find's da
eigentlich ganz gut. Wenn's jetzt natürlich irgendwelche
wirklich interessanten
Sachen gibt,
ähm, bin ich da auch
prinzipiell dabei.
So, schauen wir mal. Also,
was macht man hier alles?
Ihre Aufgaben. Ja, so, was ich noch sagen wollte. Das war letztes
Jahr übrigens richtig cool. Ich hab ja Ende letzten Jahres
auch mal kurz gesagt, ähm, so
nach dem Motto hier. Jungs, übrigens, ab nächstes Jahr,
ähm, und zwei Tage später
oder einen Tag später, hatte ich drei Sachen in der
Inbox.
Da war ich ja echt überrascht.
Aber anscheinend ist es mittlerweile
so, dass so
händeringend fähige Leute gesucht werden.
Wenn ich mich mal selbst so
bezeichnen darf, ja.
Ähm, dass
es mittlerweile teilweise schon
Reverse-Bewerben
ist. Und ich krieg das
ja auch mit, bei uns paar
unsere externen Leute. Da
vergeht, der ruft ja dreimal
am Tag irgendeinen Headhunter oder so
irgendeinen Personalverschacherungsmensch an
und will wissen, was los ist.
Die suchen alle händeringend neue Leute.
Ich glaube, es
ist gar nicht so schwierig, neue Leute
zu finden,
ähm, wenn man nicht so einen großen Anspruch hat.
Wenn man aber halt, also vom Niveau her.
Also, es gibt, denke ich, genug Leute,
wenn man, ähm,
einfach nur jemand sucht, der ein bisschen Windows-Gram
machen kann. Oder einfach jemand sucht, der
ein bisschen, ein bisschen Basic,
ähm, Web-Hosting-Geschichten
machen kann oder sowas in der Richtung. Oder
irgendwelche, äh, Basic-Geschichten.
Ja, da wirst du wahrscheinlich
massig finden, an jeder Ecke.
Aber wenn du Leute suchst,
die ein bisschen, äh,
sagen wir mal, auch ein bisschen advancederen Kenntnisstand haben,
oder vielleicht auch schon ein bisschen
mehrjährige Erfahrung,
da gibt's einfach nicht so viel.
Ich meine, wir hatten Leute,
die haben gesagt, sie haben langjährige
Dienungserfahrung. Und was haben sie gemacht?
Sie haben Ubuntu in VMware installiert.
Das ist dehnbar mittlerweile.
Und die ganzen, die ganzen Profile,
die du so siehst, die sind ja auch
alle, alles von irgendwelchen
Personalvermittlungstypen frisiert.
Die sind teilweise so frisiert, dass die Leute, die sie dann
sehen, selbst gar nicht mehr wissen, dass das, dass das
da überhaupt drin stand. Ja, Flo96,
schön wär's, ne?
Next Level, Big Brain.
Ja, guck mal mal. Also, was, was suchen
die hier denn?
Aber die Anzeige sieht schon mal ganz okay aus.
Ich hoffe, wir finden mal wieder so eine
richtige Bullshit-Anzeige,
wie wir beim letzten Mal gucken gefunden haben.
Die, die quasi drei Personen
in einem gesucht haben.
Ich müsste, glaube ich, echt mal,
dass, dass auch jemand, der vielleicht mal
im Stream das mitkriegt, ich müsste mal
so eine Skills-Seite machen. Das können wir auch im,
das machen wir im Stream zusammen.
Wir machen mal so einen, so einen, wie nennt man das?
Kein Lebenslauf, sondern
so einen,
wie heißt denn das?
So eine Seite, wo man reinschreibt, was man kann.
Das machen wir mal on Stream.
Portfolio, sowas in der Richtung, genau.
So Skillset.
Ne, Resümee ist ja eher so ein Lebenslauf.
Lebenslauf machen wir bestimmt nicht on Stream.
Ja, weil ich meine, die Streams gehen ja wirklich in alle
möglichen Richtungen hier, ja. Wir machen, wir
machen Linux-Gefrickel.
Wir machen irgendwelche
Programmiergeschichten. Wir machen eigentlich alles hier irgendwie
on Stream. Ach, Auskennfuchs,
also wir, ich glaube,
da wird auch ein bisschen zu sehr der Teufel
an die Wand gemalt, dass man Leute für Basic
Aufgaben nicht mehr braucht.
Man braucht vielleicht nicht
mehr ganz so viele,
aber du wirst immer Leute brauchen, die
Basic Sachen machen.
Sei es nur Druckerpatronen wechseln.
Äh, Hexor, das ist,
wundert mich nicht, also
viele, vieles, wo Consultant dransteht,
sind Leute, wo ich mich
ernsthaft frage, zu was auch immer ich die
überhaupt konsultieren soll. Consultant
wirkt, der hört sich ja vom Wort her immer so an,
als ist das jemand, den kann
ich fragen, den kann ich konsultieren, wenn ich
selber nicht mehr weiter weiß.
Allerdings die meisten Consultants, die ich kenne,
wüsste ich gar nicht, wozu ich die fragen
soll. Das ist eher so, dass
jeder, der nichts kann, ein Consultant wird.
Gefühlt, ja. Tut man wahrscheinlich auch
einigen Unrecht, die tatsächlich Ahnung
haben, aber
so der 0815,
wie sagt man, Feld-, Wald- und Wiesen-
Consultant,
den man so sieht, der hat auch keinen Plan.
Das sieht man ja auch
schon daran. Wir hatten mal einen Azubi,
der hatte wirklich keinen blassen Schimmer,
habe ich glaube ich sogar mal
in einem Video erzählt damals, und er hat es irgendwie
geschafft, seine Abschlussprüfung hinzukriegen,
was auch wieder nicht für die Qualität der IHK
Abschlussprüfung spricht.
Bei uns wusste
keiner, irgendwas mit ihm anzufangen,
das heißt, es wollte ihn auch keiner haben,
dementsprechend wurde er auch nicht übernommen, so das Alibi
halbe Jahr wurde er übernommen,
einfach, dass es nicht zu schlecht aussieht, also um ihm
Gefallen zu tun im Endeffekt,
und um ihn
halt nicht so assi rauszukicken,
ja. Es ist ja schon mal, spricht auch für die
Firma, dass sie das machen.
Und was ist er danach geworden?
Junior-Consultant bei irgendeinem Consulting-Laden.
Und das war wirklich jemand,
ich hätte,
mir fällt nichts ein, wozu
ich ihn hätte konsultieren sollen.
Nichts!
Doch!
Vielleicht,
was für einen Louis Vuitton-Anzug man sich holen soll,
oder sowas. Der hatte immer gerne Anzüge angehabt,
die der Vater bezahlt hat.
Ähm,
das ist aber das einzige, was mir einfällt,
was ich konsultieren könnte.
Oder Eis, Eis holen, er war öfters
Eis holen, weil jemand gerade Kaffee holen geschrieben hat.
Hast du viel
mit Azubis zu tun? Früher schon,
jetzt eigentlich kaum noch, weil wir irgendwie so wenig Azubis haben.
Okay, also,
gucken wir uns mal, ähm,
Goethestraße, Louis Vuitton-Store,
zahl die Kollektion
bar, fick auf Sponsor.
Okay, gucken wir uns
auf
die Abi.
So, gucken wir uns mal an, also, was suchen die denn?
Ausbau, Weiterentwicklung
und Performanceoptimierung
der fahrenden Linux-Systemlandschaft.
Das wäre schon mal was für mich.
Konzeption und Aufbau von
Webserverlösungen.
Warum nicht?
Konzeption, also, würde ich auch machen.
Ist immer komplett davon abhängig,
was die, was die genau haben wollen,
aber prinzipiell würde mich das auch ansprechen.
Konzeption und Aufbau von Containerlösungen
bin ich auch sofort dabei. Projektarbeit
zur Optimierung, äh,
zur Implementierung, Optimierung
und Regeltausch
der IT-Infrastruktur
und Erstellung der
Betriebsdokumente, Moment, was?
Projektarbeit zur Implementierung,
Optimierung
und Regeltausch.
Meinen die damit sowas wie,
dass die Dinger regelmäßig geupdatet werden oder sowas?
Also sowas wie,
äh,
dass man, dass man so einen, so einen,
so einen Lifecycle-Management irgendwie hat,
so, Kiste kommt rein,
äh, drei Jahre später fliegt Kiste wieder raus,
oder?
Was ist damit gemeint? Habt ihr ne Ahnung,
was, was, was das hier?
Okay, findet man nicht mal bei Google was sinnvolles.
Ähm,
lassen wir mal
Regeltausch weg. Implementierung,
Optimierung der IT-Infrastruktur.
Es ist unglücklich formuliert.
Ich glaube, das liegt daran, dass das
irgendein, ähm, Personalabteilungs-
Mensch wahrscheinlich geschrieben hat, da keine Ahnung hat,
was, was die eigentlich haben wollen.
Und Erstellung der Betriebsdokumentation.
Das ist jetzt alles so ein bisschen
übergreifend.
Ich meine,
klar, dass man dokumentiert,
was man macht, ist okay.
Dass man aber
quasi das, was schon alles da ist,
äh,
archäologisch aufbereiten soll, würde ich
jetzt nicht unbedingt zu einem
Senior,
Moment, das ist ja gar kein Senior DevOps.
Doch. Zu einem Senior-DevOps-Engineer.
zählen.
Egal. Evaluierung, Einführung
und Betrieb von Automatisierungslösungen
für die Betriebsprozesse der vorhandenen
Ja, klar.
Na, zum Beispiel, dass du Server automatisch aufbauen
kannst, dass immer wieder das gleiche System hintenbei rauskommt.
Was auch immer mit was,
mit Ansible, mit Chef, mit Puppet, mit
hast du nicht gesehen, mit irgendwelchen,
äh, Docker-Files, Containerlösungen,
also, ja, das ist eindeutig
Aufgabe davon. Evaluierung
neuer Technologien und technische Hilfsmittel zur
stetigen Verbesserung und Automatisierung
des Systembetriebs. Ah, ja.
Uah!
Java S. Sie haben das Wort
gesagt. Unterstützung
von Java-Entwicklern und Fehleranalyse
inklusive Dokumentation. Ja, okay,
ist schon, ist in Ordnung.
Ist in Ordnung, aber ich...
Java.
Allerdings darf ich nicht so tun, das machen wir jetzt
auch schon, weil wir haben auch relativ viel Java-Software.
Aber ich reiß mich nicht rum.
Durchführung
von Rufbereitschaften, Wartungs- und Routinearbeiten.
Ich habe
irgendwie das Gefühl,
dass die auch
mehrere Leute suchen.
Die suchen einen Server-Admin,
die suchen einen
Support-Mitarbeiter und die suchen jemand,
der ein bisschen DevOps macht.
Liest sich vermindern...
Liest sich nicht
nach einer klar definierten
Position irgendwie.
Du arbeitest da!
Wer schreibt denn da die...
Wer schreibt denn da die, ähm...
Sind das die Teams,
die wirklich Leute suchen,
oder ist das die Personalabteilung?
Für mich liest sich ein bisschen wie
die Personalabteilung.
Habe ich recht mit meiner Vermutung,
wenn man fragen darf,
dass sie eigentlich eher nach drei Leuten
suchen, statt nach einem?
Achso, okay.
Okay,
ihr Profil.
Blablabla, fundierte
Kenntnisse...
Was heißt fundierte Kenntnisse?
Ich mache das seit...
Ich benutze das seit fast 20 Jahren.
Also ich würde...
Das kann man nicht nur fundierte Kenntnisse nennen.
Auch passt...
Passt auch...
Ah, Ansible ist es.
Das ist nicht Papa, das ist nicht Chef,
das ist Ansible.
Kenntnisse in den Bereichen
Netzwerk, Firewall, VPN,
Router, Switche,
VMware oder MySQL?
Es wird immer merkwürdig.
Ist okay.
Er passt aber nicht so wirklich hier oben
zu.
Weil ich meine,
VPN, Router, Netze
ist mal wieder was komplett anderes, als das,
was da oben drin steht.
Das sind nicht nur zwei Stellen, das sind drei
Stellen in einem.
Das sind...
Ja, das sind auch keine Skripte, Steinex.
Ansible ist ja im Prinzip einfach nur so
ein langes Beschreibungsjammel.
Weiß ich auch nicht.
Aber das hat wahrscheinlich jemand geschrieben, da keine Ahnung.
Die suchen drei Leute.
Die suchen einen Support-Mensch,
die suchen einen Admin.
Vier Leute. Die suchen einen Support-Mensch,
die suchen einen Admin, die suchen einen, der ein bisschen DevOps macht
und die suchen einen Netzwerker.
Okay, die bieten also...
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Er hat mich jetzt nicht so angesprochen.
Senior DevOps Engineer
Mobile Anwendung.
Oh Gott, ich glaube, ich weiß, wo das ist.
Ich habe mal von einer Bahn
auf Twitter
angeschrieben, nachdem ich so krass
geflamed habe über ihre...
über ihre...
Ich habe noch nicht mal über die App geflamed.
Ich habe über alles geflamed von einer Bahn.
Und nachdem es ja bei mir auf Twitter auch ab und zu
ein paar Leute lesen, da hat mich dann jemand
von einer Bahn angeschrieben, ob ich nicht mal vorbei...
ob ich nicht mal vorbeikommen will und
ihre...
irgendwie...
Ich weiß gar nicht, was er geschrieben hat.
Ob ich nicht
in ihrem Innovationscenter vorbeikommen
will, mich mal mit dem App
Team unterhalten, was ich für
vorstelle. Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Wo ich erst gedacht habe, so ey,
das Angebot ist eigentlich echt cool.
Ich meine, warum nicht? Auf der anderen
Seite habe ich mir gedacht,
erstens vorbeikommen und zweitens
ey, das ist doch nicht mein Job, denen zu
sagen, wie sie die App ordentlich machen sollen.
Wir können einen Beratungsvertrag machen oder so.
Die entführen dich
direkt, ja. Direkt weg.
Verschleppt
in ICE. Also was
haben sie denn von der Bahn?
Wenn es darum geht, zukünftig
übliche bla bla bla, aber
recht kurz gehalten.
Zum nächstmöglichen Zeitpunkt suchen wir
dich als Senior DevOps Engineer am Standort
Frankfurt am Main. Das agile Team
Mobile
Produktentwicklung, ach die heißen
so, such dich im Bereich
Build Management Continuous Integration
Continuous Integration.
In diesem Bereich könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen, was drin zu machen.
Deine Aufgaben.
Mit deiner Expertise unterstützt
du die Entwicklungsteams im Bereich Build
Management Continuous Delivery.
Ja klar, dafür suchen sie auch einen.
Du führst Release-Vorbereitungen durch
und übergibst die Softwarepakete an Tester
und Betrieb.
Das passt schon ziemlich gut.
In die Richtung zu dem,
wo ich Erfahrung drin hab.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich
zur Bahn will.
Dingsbums, das wäre mal eine geile Idee.
Das wäre mal eine geile Idee.
Man müsste sich bei der Bahn bewerben
und mit dem Zug
zum Bewerbungsgespräch fahren und dann
Verspätung haben, weil der Zug nicht rechtzeitig gekommen ist.
Die können da eigentlich
doch überhaupt nichts sagen, oder?
Die können doch eigentlich gar nicht
die können doch da eigentlich nicht absagen
so nach dem Motto, jetzt müssen sie auch gar nicht mehr kommen.
Das ist ja quasi
selbstverschuldet.
Ist Continuous Integration
Continuous Delivery
eine Systemintegrationssache oder eine
Anwendungsentwicklungssache? Beides.
Deswegen hat man
noch diese Sachen mittlerweile
den DevOps-Stempel
aufgedrückt, weil es früher
quasi so in der Schwebe war.
Weil es weder genau
Anwendungsentwicklung noch genau Systemintegration ist.
Es ist keine klassische Sache,
wir administrieren jetzt einen Server.
Es ist aber auch nichts, wir programmieren jetzt eine Anwendung.
Das ist quasi was dazwischen.
DevOps halt.
Du stellst was
bereit oder entwickelst was,
was unter anderem Entwicklern hilft
ihre Arbeit besser zu machen
oder dass die Softwarequalität
verbessert
oder dass die ganzen Sachen reproduzierbarer macht.
Das ist nicht wirklich
klassische Systemadministration.
Das ist auch nicht Anwendungsentwicklung.
Deswegen, ich finde es eigentlich ganz gut, dass sie der Sache mal
einen Namen gegeben haben mit DevOps.
Weil im Endeffekt ist das das,
was ich seit 15 Jahren schon mache.
Bloß, dass das erst seit den letzten
5-6 Jahren DevOps heißt überhaupt.
Okay, also.
Ebenfalls
gehört ein umfassendes
Build und Delivery Management unter anderem verwendete Tools.
Jenkins, oh das ist Java.
Das ist Java, so nah
Cradle Maven Jenkins.
Das ist Java.
Java S.
Du bist für das Design und Entwicklung
von Software Delivery
Pipelines, das ist auch so ein schönes Wort,
was aktuell alle mögen, zuständig und
stellst somit eine hohe Qualität der ausgelieferten
Software sicher. Okay.
Kann alles mit gemeint sein.
Darunter fallen auch die
4 Aufgabenschwerpunkte.
Einrichten von Jobs im
Jenkins.
Das sind ein paar Klicks
im Webinterface.
Jenkins Jobs einrichten.
Jobs in Jenkins
einrichten ist tatsächlich
Die Schwierigkeit könnte daher kommen,
wenn nicht genau spezifiziert ist, was die
Jenkins Jobs machen sollen.
Die Konfiguration von Quality Gates
und Verbesserung der Effizienz
der Pipelines.
Alter, was ein krasser Business
Speak, oder?
Wisst ihr was ein Quality Gate ist?
Im Prinzip ist das ein
so ein bisschen was wie eine
Prüfung.
Ist Jenkins und Maven das gleiche?
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Ehm, Quality Gate
ist im Prinzip
so ein Überprüfungs
Prozess könnte man das
Ganze nennen.
Also, wo definiert wird,
was beispielsweise, wenn neue Sachen
gebaut werden, oder wenn neue Sachen entwickelt werden,
dann wird definiert, was muss das Ding
ähm, keine Ahnung.
Wir haben als Anforderung,
dass wir
keine Ahnung
Mindestversionen da und da
von verwenden. Wir haben als
Anforderung, es muss unter Red Hat
Linux laufen. Wir haben als Anforderung,
es muss sich integrieren
lassen mit unserer
Authentifizierungsmechanismus.
Irgendwie sowas, ja.
Das sind dann Punkte, die stehen im Quality Gate drinne
und durch dieses Quality Gate muss
dann quasi dieses Produkt durch. Und wenn das dann
durch ist, dann ist gut. Also, das ist halt
Eigentlich wird nur
geguckt, dass es auch die Vorgaben einhält.
geguckt, dass die Vorgaben einhält.
Und da versteht auch jeder Laden ein bisschen was
anderes
drunter. Ja genau,
Turbodata.
Validation des erstellten Zeugs.
Also genau, gucken, dass die Sachen, die definiert
sind oder Vorgaben sind auch eingehalten
werden.
Verbesserung der Effizienz der Pipelines.
Also das ist wirklich gerade ein Business Talk
Satz.
Automatisierung manueller Aufgaben.
Das ist tatsächlich die Sache, die würde ich
eindeutig zu einem
DevOps-Aufgabe von einem DevOps-Engineer
zählen.
Dokumentation der Build-Prozesse.
Naja.
Dein Profil.
Du verfügst über
geprägte Kenntnisse und
Erfahrungen in Continuous Integration, Continuous Delivery
sowie den verbundenen Werkzeugen.
Jenkins? Ja.
Git?
Auf jeden Fall.
Das ist mein täglich
Brot.
Maven?
Ich weiß, was es ist.
Absichtlich bisher noch nichts mitgemacht.
Cradle?
Ich weiß nicht mal ganz genau, was es ist.
Auf jeden Fall sind das Java-Dinger.
War Cradle nicht ein Web-Framework?
Ein Java-Web-Framework?
Oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Ach nee.
Das ist irgendein Build-Tool.
Maven ist quasi dort, wo das fertig
kompilierte Zeug dann eingecheckt wird.
Docker? Ja.
Kubernetes? Ja.
Zudem kennst du dich in gängigen
Programmiersprachen und Technologien aus.
Wie? C? C++?
Java? Java Enterprise?
JBoss? REST? MySQL?
Okay, das ist eine relativ
unzusammenhängende Liste.
Das passt zusammen.
Das passt zu keinem davon.
Und das auch nicht.
Aber okay.
Man hat halt einfach mal so ein bisschen best-of gemacht.
Okay, ähm.
Agile Methoden.
Ich bin sowas von agil.
Ich bin nicht mal mehr agil.
Ich bin schon komplett agile.
Deine Persönlichkeit zeichnet sich
zudem durch deinen
wertschätzenden Umgang mit anderen
und deine Fähigkeit
zum Netzwerken aus.
Okay, da fall ich schon mal raus.
Also nicht wegen dem ersten Teil.
In der Regel komme ich
eigentlich mit Leuten ganz gut
klar, wenn
sie sich nicht darauf anlegen, einen zu triggern.
Ist ja immer eine
beidseitige Sache.
Und ich verstehe mich mit
den meisten Leuten, die
auch nicht darauf anlegen, dass man sich
nicht mit ihnen versteht. Auch ganz gut.
Das ist eigentlich kein Problem. Allerdings,
das hier,
was ja im Endeffekt heißt,
ähm,
jede Menge Smalltalk.
Da bin ich
der Falsche für.
Kaffee mit Salz. Twitch Prime. Dankeschön.
Nice.
Super. Dankeschön.
Und den haben wir als nächstes. Klar.
Oh, es ist 22 Uhr. Ich muss ins Bett.
Muss ins Bett.
Kann man das auch ohne Ausbildung ETC machen,
wenn man sich sehr gut auskennt? Können kannst du
das bestimmt, wenn du dich damit gut auskennst, aber wahrscheinlich
wird dich keiner nehmen.
Es sei denn,
du hast da drin schon jahrelange
Erfahrung. Dann wird es keinen jucken.
Was du aber wahrscheinlich ohne Ausbildung eher
weniger hast, denke ich mal.
Oh, das Ganze ist auf Englisch. Da habe ich keinen
Bock drauf.
Lead DevOps Engineer.
Nach vorne denken.
Top Management Beratung.
Na gut, es ist egal. Ganz ehrlich,
äh, ich bin da viel zu kritisch, wenn ich
diese Anzeigen lese, was es für Läden
sind.
Für mich als jemand, der was mit der Technik da zu tun hat,
ist es scheißegal, ob die irgendwelche
Management Consultant Dudes sind oder nicht.
Solange ich mit den,
die Consultant nichts zu tun habe.
Ähm.
Aufbau von DevOps Toolchains.
Source Control Repo. Jawoll.
Continuous. Jawoll.
Static Code Anlösung. Mach ich auch.
Binary. Binary
Repository. Da meinen die sowas
wie Maven mit, oder?
Ich meine, es gibt verschiedene. Du kannst, du kannst
Binary auch in einem, in einem zusätzlichen
Git-File-System, GitFS oder irgendwie
sowas, was auch immer damit genau gemeint ist.
Binary Repository.
Ähm. Deployment Automation.
Über verschiedene Umgebungen.
Konfigurations. Also davon fühle ich mich
angesprochen.
Das trifft es eigentlich ganz gut.
Implementierung und Orchestrierung
von Containern. Ja, fühle ich mich auch
mit angesprochen. Aufbau von
Monitoring und Alerting System fühle ich mich auch
von angesprochen.
Weil das oftmals auch schon wieder nicht ein und dieselbe Person
macht. Continuous
Improvement von Produktionssystemen
beispielsweise durch Beseitigung von Tech-
Technical Debt.
Schreibt man das so?
Also das ist, damit ist Schuld
gemeint. Schreibt man das so?
Ich glaube schon. Ja, das schreibt man so.
Nein.
Wenn man nicht weiß, was
man schreibt, ja. Ja doch,
ich dachte mir die ganze Zeit schon, das Wort
sieht irgendwie komisch aus.
Gut, das hat wieder jemand
geschrieben, der keinen blassen Schimmer hat, was sie eigentlich
suchen.
Also was damit gemeint ist,
um mal zu erklären, was damit
gemeint ist, das ist für den
Außenstehenden wahrscheinlich relativ
unverständlich, was damit gemeint ist.
Also,
die meinen damit,
dass man die Systeme kontinuierlich
verbessert, zum Beispiel
durch das
Abschneiden alter Zöpfe.
Heißt das auf Deutsch.
Also sprich,
mit Technical Debt, also mit
Schuld, ist quasi gemeint,
dass man über Jahrzehnte
irgendwelche alten Hacks mit sich
rumschleppt, anstatt
das mal ordentlich zu machen.
Allerdings ist das
eher eine Sache, wo
sich komplette Teams drum kümmern müssen.
Na gut.
Müssen wir nicht so kritisch sein,
dass das aber jemand
geschrieben hat, der glaube ich nicht genau weiß, was er schreibt,
dass das wahrscheinlich Personalabteilung geschrieben hat
und das für eine andere Abteilung ist.
Naja.
Und Automatisierung.
Site Reliability Engineering.
Mittlerweile gibt es echt für alles
irgendwelche krassen Begriffe, oder?
Das fällt mir schwer
sogar auszusprechen.
Site Reliability Engineering.
Also, dass der Scheiß läuft, auf gut Deutsch.
Unsere Erwartungen.
Blablablub.
Programmieren ist Ihre Leidenschaft.
Ja.
Also, an sich spricht mich
das schon an, was die da suchen.
Erfahrung
mit gängigen CI-Tools.
GitLab, Jenkins, Sonar, das ist ja schon wieder
Java. Aber gut.
Java kannst du nicht vermeiden, das ist Business.
Ja, bei uns gibt es auch viel Java.
Erfahrung
im Scripting und im Umgang
mit Containern.
Engagierte, gewissenhafte
Arbeitsweise mit verinnerlichter
No-Playing
Gaming und Sharing Culture.
Das finde ich gut,
dass sie das reinschreiben.
Ich glaube, es gibt aber nicht viele
Läden, wo das wirklich
auch gemacht wird.
Also, was ist damit gemeint?
Es ist einfach, man soll nicht gucken,
wer es kaputt gemacht hat, sondern man soll
gucken, dass es wieder geht
und dass es nicht wieder passiert.
Vollkommen egal, wer es kaputt gemacht hat.
Finde ich aber gut, dass sie das reinschreiben.
Trainings inklusive
Zertifizierung, wenn es sein muss.
Work-Life-Balance, Vereinbarkeit von
Kind, Karriere, Arbeitszeit, Konto,
mobiles Arbeiten.
Das ist irgendwie, dass man ein bisschen,
dass man irgendwie mal weniger arbeiten kann
und ach, was auch immer.
PME-Familien-Service, ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Was ist das?
Mitarbeiterunterstützung
in allen Lebenslagen von Betreuern.
Okay.
Scheint schon mal nicht schlecht zu sein.
Bahnfahren,
Bahnkarten 25, 1. Klasse,
geschäftlich und privat.
Firmenwagenregelung.
Bahnkarten bringt mir halt,
Bahnkarten 25 bringt mir jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig was, ne?
Aber ich finde schon mal gut,
dass sie das überhaupt reinschreiben.
Fahrradflat.
Das ist auch ganz cool.
Ich meine, das sind mal wenigstens welche,
die Vorteile hinschreiben,
die man auch als Vorteile sehen kann,
ja? Nicht so diese Sachen,
ihre Vorteile sind,
äh, führende in unserem Bereich.
Who cares? Ja, aber die machen das schon mal richtig.
Innovation.
Nutzung unserer Digilabs
zur Entwicklung kreativer Ideen
mit modernsten Technologien.
Keine Ahnung.
Unser Mindset.
Teamspirit, offene Türen, Dudeskultur.
Finde ich okay.
Wertschätzung
über alle Ebenen hinweg.
In Hamburg? Moment.
Ich denke in Frankfurt.
Wo sind die in Frankfurt?
Ich hasse,
ich hasse es, wenn man so macht,
dass man Google Maps nicht scrollen kann.
Taunusanlage,
Main Tower, der Hauptbahnhof.
Ah, das ist um die Ecke.
So bin ich direkt da.
Die fand ich jetzt gar nicht so blöd.
Steuerung und Scrollen, okay.
Moment, wo ist die Karte hin?
Karte ist weg.
Die Karte ist weg.
Steuerung und Scrollen geht auch nicht.
Moin, auf der Suche
nach einer neuen Stelle und nur mal aus Spaß.
Eigentlich just for fun.
Ich will einfach mal gucken,
was es gibt.
Wenn es irgendwas super geiles gibt,
bin ich da natürlich nicht abgeneigt.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich sage,
ich brauche unbedingt was Neues.
Eigentlich
ein bisschen just for fun zu gucken,
was es so gibt.
Die fand ich gar nicht blöd.
Auch halt ein bisschen merkwürdig,
wie es geschrieben war und dass sie beispielsweise auch
ihre eigenen Sachen nicht richtig geschrieben haben.
Also nach dem Motto, wir verwenden halt die super
trendigen neuen Begriffe,
aber wissen gar nicht selbst, was die Begriffe eigentlich heißen.
Aber das wäre jetzt nicht schlimm.
Das macht sie mir jetzt nicht unbedingt unsympathischer
oder so.
Fand ich ganz gut. War eine ordentliche Anzeige.
So, Leute.
Ich muss pennen.
Ich muss morgen wieder 5.45 Uhr aufstehen auf die Arbeit.
Hör mal jetzt Schluss.
Gucken, ob es noch
irgendjemand gibt, den wir hosten können.
Wem kann man folgen?
Nicht folgen. Wen kann ich hosten?
Jemand, den ich kenne.
Von denen, denen ich folge.
Nope, keiner da.
Wen haben wir denn hier?
Meine erste Wasserkühlung live
zusammengebaut, inklusive
Fails.
Katze!
Egal, Leute. Ich kann jetzt nicht weiter gucken.
Ich muss pennen, sonst
komme ich morgen nicht aufs Bett.
Macht's gut. Bis zum nächsten Mal.